AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE HEARING TOGETHER TO ORDER A
FROM UTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE- THIS IS OUR ANNUAL
MEETING WITH THE CP YOU SEE AND
OUR NEW PRESIDENT- SO IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE
BRIEFED ON THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE UTILITY REGULATORY AGENCY
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND TO GET
THEIR INSIDE AND PUT ON A
VARIETY OF SUBJECT MATTER AND
IT ALSO GIVES THE COMMITTEE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS SO
THIS WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US ALL TO ENGAGE AND WITH LAST
YEAR BEING SUCH A- NO PUN
INTENDED HIGH ENERGY YEAR-
THIS- SHOULD PRODUCE I THINK
HOPEFULLY SOME. IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION BUT BEFORE WE GET
STARTED AND I ASK MAYOR BILL
BADGER PRESIDENT OF CPC TO COME
FORWARD I WANT TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE A NEW
MEMBER OF OUR COMMITTEE AS OUR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY- WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO HAVE AN S. AND CAROL
IS FOR A NEW SECRETARY AND SHE
COMES TO US FROM BEING THE
COMMITTEE SO. OF THE PREVIOUSLY
I CAN THE ASSISTANT TO SAY AS-
AND HOW AMENDED UNDERSTAND OF
LEGISLATIVE. AND WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE YOU JOIN ME IN GENERAL
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE. I JUST
GOING TO SAY A FEW BRIEF
OPENING COM THEN I'LL TURN TO
OUR CHAIR FOR HIM TO. HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS TO AS WE AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM PRO BADGERED.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE ARE
CERTAINLY TALK TO MY TIME IN
THE- SO. AND THOUSAND NINE MAY
ISSUE INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF OR P. S. P. S.
EVENTS WREAKED HAVOC. ON THE
CITIZENS OF THE STATE.
SHORTFALLS IN GENERATION SUPPLY
WERE IDENTIFIED ELECTRICITY
RATES CONTINUE TO INCREASE AT
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
DECLARED BANKRUPTCY. EACH OF
THESE ISSUES A SIGNIFICANT AND
INDICATIVE OF THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THE
REGULATORY ENTITY CHARGED WITH
OVERSEEING OUR VITAL UTILITY
SERVICES. AS WE HAVE SADLY
FOUND EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS
HAVE BECOME MUCH TOO COMMON IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS DIRECTED
BY PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
SHATTERED PUBLIC CONFIDENCE. IN
THOSE UTILITIES AND IN THE
INSTITUTIONS RICH WHICH
REGULATE THEM. THE PS PS EVENTS
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BECAUSE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP TO RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES IN THE AREA IS
SERVED BY THOSE UTILITIES.
INCREASING THE GRAVITY OF THE
SITUATION IS THE FACT THAT
THESE UTILITIES WERE ILL
PREPARED TO COMMUNICATE WITH
CUSTOMERS IN REAL TIME. THE
INABILITY OF THE UTILITIES TO
INFORM THEIR CUSTOMERS ABOUT
THE DURATION OF THE OUTAGES AND
THE PRECAUTIONS THEY SHOULD FIX
THAT IT SHOULD HAVE TAKEN
EXACERBATED THE HORRIFIC
SITUATION. MILLION OF CUT
MILLIONS OF CUSTOMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CONTENT
WITH BLACKOUTS THAT LASTED
MULTIPLE DAYS. WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM THE
PRESS FROM PRESIDENT BADGER
ABOUT THE ACTIONS THE CPUC HAS
TAKEN TO MITIGATE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS INCLUDING THE NECESSARY
GREAT HARDENING AND ENHANCE
COMMUNICATIONS. MOVING TO THE
MATTER OF GENERATIONS SUPPLY
SHORTAGES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT
WAS DISTURBING TO LEARN A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
GENERATION SHORTAGES WHICH SEEM
TO CATCH THE CPUC BY SURPRISE
IT APPEARS THAT THREE FACTORS
LARGELY CONTRIBUTED TO THE
SHORTFALL. FIRST A DECADE AGO
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ADOPTED
REGULATIONS THAT WOULD LEAD TO
THE RETIREMENT OF NATURAL GAS
PLANTS THAT RELY UON OCEAN
WATER FOR COOLING. THE
COMPLIANCE DATE IS NEARLY UPON
US. MANY OF THESE THERMAL
PLANTS ALONG THE COAST
CURRENTLY PROVIDE GENERATION
AND RELIABILITY SERVICES.
SECOND IT WASN'T UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT THE CQC
LOWERED THE CAPACITY FACTOR
FROM SOLAR. WHICH LED TO A NEAR
THE RIVERS LED TO A NEED FOR
REPLACEMENT GENERATION. THIRD
AND THIRD TANK THANKFULLY COAL
PLANTS IN THE INTERCONNECTED
WESTERN GRID ARE RETIRING.
THOSE RETIREMENTS OF CAUSE A
REDUCTION OF GENERATION
AVAILABLE FOR IMPORT. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND WHY THE
CPUC DID NOT APPRECIATE THE
GRAVITY OF THE SHORTFALL SOONER
AND TAKE ACTION TO MITIGATE ITS
IMPACT. WE'RE ANXIOUS TO HEAR
WHAT STEPS TO CEBU CITY HAS
INSTITUTED TO ADDRESS APPARENT
DEFICIENCIES IN SYSTEM MODELING.
LET ME BRIEFLY MOVED TO
ELECTRICITY RATES. SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC ELECTRIC UTILITY
YOUR ELECTRICITY RATES HAVE
INCREASED BY APPROXIMATELY 50%
IN TEN YEARS. IT APPEARS THAT
SDG ANNE'S RATES ARE A
HARBINGER OF INCREASES IN THE
OTHER UTILITY TO UTILITIES
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS
AND ENERGY SERVICE PROVIDERS.
IT WILL BE INCREASINGLY
CHALLENGING TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS WHICH RELY UPON GREATER
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION RESIDENTIAL AND
BUSINESS SECTOR OF ELECTRICITY
RATES CONTINUE TO INCREASE AT
THEIR CURRENT RATE. WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
PRESIDENT BADGER ABOUT ACTIONS
THIS INSTITUTION COULD TAKE TO
BRING DOWN RATES. FINALLY LET
ME TURN TO THE BANKRUPTCY OF P.
GINNY. MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE JOINS ME IN THE
PASSAGE OF A C. R. SEVENTY
EIGHT. THAT BILL ARTICULATES
THE LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES
AND CALLS UPON REPRESENT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE
SPECIFIC PRIORITIES IN ITS
FILINGS WITH THE U. S.
BANKRUPTCY COURT. AMONG THE
PRIORITIES ARE ENSURING THE
VICTIMS OF WILDFIRE CLAIMS ARE
RESOLVED PROMPTLY AND EQUITABLY.
EMPLOYEES CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
WAGES AND BENEFITS AND THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND MANDATES OR
ACHIEVED AND RATES ARE STABLE
AND REASONABLE. WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING HOW THE CPUC
AS FULFILLING THESE PRIORITIES.
I BEFORE I TURN TO YOU- A
PRESENT BETTER- AND AGAIN
WELCOME AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR SIMON- I'D LIKE TO I'D
LIKE TO TURN- I SHOULD SAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
ASSIGNMENT IN WILL WELCOME BUT-
WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE A FOR THE
TASK. BUT I'D LIKE TO TURN TO
MY VICE CHAIR AND GIVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW
OPENING COMMENTS. AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN. WELCOME PRESIDENT
AFTER I THAT WERE. ABOUT THAT
ALL RIGHT THEN. I'M I LIKE TO
THE LINE MY COMMENTS JUST OF
THAT OF THE HE- I THINK STRUCK
THE- RIGHT NOTES IN THE TONE
AND THE LIST OF THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT. KEEP US AWAKE AT
NIGHT AND BECAUSE S. REAL
CONCERN. AM I WANTED TO QUICKLY
JUST POINT TO- WHAT I HAVE HAD
A CONCERN OVER SENSE BEING VICE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THAT IS. THE ARK. OF COSTS THAT
GO UP WHILE THE ARK OF
RELIABILITY COMES DOWN THIS
WHOLE SUPPLY DEMAND. GENERATION
AND ALL OF THAT. AND IT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL FIRST PRIORITY IS
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON TO KEEP
THEM AFFORDABLE. AND TO SOME
DEGREE THAT MAY. REQUIRE SOME-
MANAGEMENT IF YOU WILL OF SOME
OF THE MANDATES AND SOME OF THE
PARTICULAR KINDS OF DECISIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
RELIABILITY OF THE COST-
EXPLOSION- THE CHAIR
REFERENCED- THE- THE NATURAL
GAS PLANTS WHOSE LIFE WAS
SUPPOSED TO END AT A PARTICULAR
TIME THAT HAS BEEN EXTENDED. IT
APPEARS TO ME OUT OF THE
NECESSITY TO HAVE BASS LOW. AND
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THOSE LIGHTS
ON- I THINK THESE ARE THE KINDS
OF WARNING SIGNALS ARE THAT.
MANY OF US ON THIS COMMITTEE I
SPECIALLY- HAVE REYES STAFF FOR
QUITE SOME TIME IT ARE TWENTY
INTO THE- TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
FOR THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
ON THE PLANET. WHERE THE HOME
IS SILICON VALLEY. AND WE HAVE
A GRID THAT IN MY JUDGMENT IS
SLOWLY DETERIORATE. AND THERE'S
A BIG CHALLENGE IN FRONT OF ALL
OF US BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING. YOU AND I HAVE
EXPERIENCE TIME TOGETHER OF
WHEN I WAS MAYOR YOU WERE PART
OF THE ADMINISTRATION- AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BACK THEN I
WILL WORKED EXCEEDINGLY WELL
WITH YOU THEN PROCEEDED THE
WORK YOU DID THEN. OBVIOUSLY
THE CONCERNS OVER THE DMV DEREK
HAVE TROUBLED US ALL I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON THE WORK THAT
YOU HAVE DONE WHEN YOU WERE THE
HEAD OF THE STRIKE GET A TEAM I
THINK WE'RE SEEING SOME
IMPROVEMENTS- AND I THINK YOUR-
YOUR FINGERPRINTS WERE ALL OVER
THAT AND I AM GRATEFUL. FOR IT.
SO I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I
THINK THIS WAS A STERLING
APPOINTMENT. OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE P. YOU SEE- I THINK
NEEDS THE KINDS OF- DEEP
HISTORY- THAT YOU BRING. A
SENSE OF THINKING OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX. BEING A DIRECT AND
CLEAR ON THE CHALLENGES WE FACE
BUT ALSO. YOUR ABILITY I THINK
TO BE. TO PRESENT TO US THE
KINDS OF ALTERNATIVES AND THAT
SOME OF THE DISCRETION
NECESSARY TO MANAGE SOMETHING
AS COMPLICATED AS OUR
ELECTRICITY GRID. SO I WELCOME
YOU I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND- WELCOME
IS IN BADGER- I'M DELIGHTED
YOU'RE WITH US. FOR SURE EARN.
FROM MY ON. IT IS MISTER
CHAIRMAN I AM YOUR DAHLE TO
HAVE TWO OF SENIORS MEMBERS OF
THE P. JOIN ME AT THE- I AM I
AM A NEW AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ANSWER ALL OF YOUR
QUESTIONS AS THOROUGHLY TODAY
AS POSSIBLE AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT INDULGENCE. SO THANK YOU-
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
VICE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN
OVERVIEW THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ACTIVITIES
OVER THE PAST YEAR. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR KIND.
OVERLY KIND COMMENTS I HOPE IN
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW YOU CAN SAY
THE SAME THING. MY NAME IS
MERRY BELL BACHELOR AND I SERVE
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE CPC. I
AM JOINED BY CAROLINE THOMAS
JACOBS- DIRECTOR OF THE WELFARE
SAFETY VISION THE NEW DIVISION
THAT WAS CREATED UNDER A. B.
TEN FORTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR. AND
FIVE SKEWS ME AND ALSO EDWARD
RIGHT THERE'S NOT A STRANGER TO
ANY OF YOU I'M SURE. DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ENERGY AND CLIMATE POLICY
DIVISION AT THE CPUC. I WAS
SWORN IN IN AUGUST SIXTH ON
AUGUST SIXTEENTH INNING IN MY
SHORT TIME. WITH THE CPUC I'VE
SEEN DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF THE
BANKRUPTCY OF OUR LARGEST
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY.
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OUTAGES JUST
NAME TO NAME A FEW. SUCH ISSUES
HAVE PRIORITIZE MY WORK. AND
THROUGH DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU
AND OTHERS AB MEMBERS. AND YOUR
STAFFS AND PARTICIPATION IN
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS OF THESE
ISSUES. OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE
ALSO PRIORITIZING YOUR WORK. I
WELCOME YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND
COLLABORATION BECAUSE IT WILL
REQUIRE A BROAD AND THOROUGH
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE WE THE
NEEDS. AND EXPECTATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WE HAD INTO NEXT
WHILE FIRE SEE. SEASONS AHEAD
OF THAT AS WELL AS OTHER.
IMAGES WE- I HAD. IS AS YOU
KNOW A SET IN FIGHTER TO THE
UTILITY WORLD I DON'T BRING. OF
X. IN INNER POLICY OR UTILITY
EGGS MANAGER TO MY- RATHER I
LEAN ON SENSE COMMON EFFECTIVE
JUST MAKING. AN ORGANISE MANAGE
PRINCE. AND A CLEAR UNDER OF
WHO I SERVE THE OF THIS GREAT
STATE. I KNOW SOME OF YOU RIGHT
NOW ARE THINKING SHE SHOULD
HAVE SAID RATE PAYERS. I
UNDERSTAND MY OBLIGATIONS AND
DUTIES TO PROTECTING RATE
PAYERS BUT WHAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE LAST TWO TO
THREE YEARS WITH RESPECT TO
WILDFIRES. AND IMPACTS THAT
THEY HAVE ADD HAD ON ALL OF US
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AT ALL
DIFFERENT LEVELS. AS I GO
THROUGH MY PRESENTATION I
REQUEST YOU NOT SEE THIS AS A
REPORT OUT BUT IS AN INVITATION
TO IDENTIFY AND COLLABORATE ON
ISSUES OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
TO THOSE WE SERVE. AND ADDRESS.
BY THE TIME I CAME TO THE SEAT.
THE LET. HAD PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR. UTILITY WILDFIRE BILL
PACKAGE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY
FOUR. AND THE ACCOMPANYING
TRAILER BILL AB ONE ELEVEN
SINCE THEN THE CPUC HAS TAKEN
VARIOUS ACTIONS TO IMPLEMENT
BOTH BILLS WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
THE WELFARE SAFETY DIVISION AND
HIRED ITS DIRECTOR. CAROLINE
THOMAS JACOBS CAROLINE- IS
SETTING UP FOR OFFICE TO
IMPLEMENT THE AGGRESSIVE GOALS
SET FORTH IN AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
WE HAVE ALSO COMMENCED CORRECT
COORDINATION WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY ON PLANNING
FOR THE TRANSFER OF THIS
DIVISION TO THE OFFICE OF
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY.
ON JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AS DICTATED BY THE STATUTE WE
ALSO ISSUED A RULING IN
DECEMBER WHICH SET PERFORMANCE
METRICS FOR THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANTS. WE
ESTABLISHED THE WELFARE FUND
AND THE WELFARE SAFETY ADVISORY
BOARD HELD ITS FIRST MEETING
JUST YESTERDAY. AS MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE THE WELFARE
MITIGATION PLAN DEVELOPED BY
EACH OF THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES IS BECOMING A KEY
FRAME MARK IN THE ASSESSING THE
PREPAREDNESS EFFECTIVENESS I-
USE IT CAN'T. VENTA YOU TELL
BECAUSE OF. AS WE AS THE EFFECT.
OF PER ELEMENTS INCLUDING THE
USE OF P. S. P. S. THE ELECTRIC
UTILITY SUBMITTED THEIR FIRST
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS W. M.
P.'S TO THE C. U. B. C. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. BASED ON
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE TWENTY
NINETEEN SUBMISSIONS AND THE
WILDFIRE SEASONS OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION AND THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION STAFF ARE
IMPLEMENTING CHANGES TO THE W.
M. P. PROCESS SUCH AS REFINING
THE W. MP GUIDELINES. THIS
REPRESENTS A MAJOR MILESTONE IN
THE EVOLUTION OF THE W. M. P.
PROCESS AS THESE GUIDELINES ARE
INTENDED TO AID IN THE
EVALUATION OF THE UTILITIES
WHILE FIRE MITIGATION EFFORTS
AND TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY WITH
THE COMMISSION'S LONG TERM.
WILDFIRE F. AND- WE HAVE A-
SOUGHT. PUBLIC PER OF. IN ALL
SEE PUBLIC ON THE NEW W. MP
GUIDELINES TEMPLATE AND
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION TOOLS TO
THE W. M. P. PROCEEDINGS THE
CPUC IS SOLICITING INPUT FROM
THE WILD SAFETY ADVISORY BOARD
FOR THIS YEAR'S W. M. PEAS AND
FOR UPDATING THE GUIDELINES
LATER THIS YEAR. AND WILL
INCORPORATE LESSONS LEARNED
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY W. M.
P. EVALUATION PROCESS THERE IS
A NEW STORE YESTERDAY THAT WAS
WRONG IN IN THAT EVALUATION AND
I WANTED TO CLEAR THAT UP.
DURING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
WILDFIRE SEASON UTILITIES
RESORTED TO P. S. P. S. AS THE
MEASURE OF LAST RESORT OFTEN
AND BROADLY. WE ARE USING THE
NEW TWENTY TWENTY WELFARE
MITIGATION PLAN GUIDELINES TO
MAKE THE UTILITIES ARTICULATE
AND I'LL I'LL TURN LEAD.
IMPLEMENT HOW THEY WILL REDUCE
THE SCALE AND SCOPE OF FUTURE
PS PS EVENTS AND WE WILL HAVE
IT DONE IN TIME WELL BEFORE THE
P. S. P. S. SEASON. WHICH IS
THE WILDFIRE SEASON FOR EXAMPLE
THIS YEAR'S WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS UTILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
TELL US HOW THEY ARE USING THE
SYSTEM HARDENING. IMPROVED
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND GRID
RE DESIGN TO REDUCE THE SCOPE
AND THE DURATION OF THE P. S.
P. S. EVENTS IN THE COMING YEAR.
CAROLINE TA JACOBS HERE TODAY
WITH ME IN THE EVENT AS I SAID
EARLIER THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
ANY MORE SPECIFICS THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR ON THE
MODELING AND THE GUIDELINES AND
INDEED THE PROGRESS. THAT THE
METRICS FOR THE W. MPS ARE
SHOWING. AND GIVEN THE IMPACT
TO PEOPLE'S LIVES AND THE
THREAT TO THEIR SAFETY AS WELL
AS A CONSIDERABLE DISRUPTION TO
COMMERCE AND TRANSPORTATION. IT
IS CRITICAL TO UNCOVER WHAT
WENT WRONG HOW THE PS PS OF
BILLS WERE MISMANAGED BY THE
UTILITIES BE ON DISTURBING
EXCUSE ME DISTRIBUTING THE NEW
GUIDELINES AND EVALUATION TOOLS
FOR THE W. M. PEAS WE ARE ALSO
INVESTIGATING ONE. THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE UTILITIES
PROCEDURES TO NOTIFY THE PUBLIC
OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN PS YES
OF HANDS. AND TELL IT IN AND CO.
FIRST LOCAL. STATE AGENT. AT
UTILITIES MANAGEMENT OF ITS
RESOURCE TO A PUBLIC SAFETY
THIS SO CA ON A NUMBER OF THE
PSP RECORD TO ADDRESS TO FISH.
FOR A THE I. O. U.'S
PARTICULARLY JEANNIE NEED TO
IMPROVE THEIR ENGAGEMENT WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE BETTER MAPS FOR THE PS
PS EVENTS THEY NEED TO
COORDINATE MORE CLOSELY WITH
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
PRIORITIZATION PS MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS BRAILLE
PRIORITIZING LOCATIONS FOR
SECTIONAL ISING DEVELOPING
MICRO GRIDS TO BUILDERS. FOR
CRITICAL SERVICES AND FOR PRE
CANA FIND INSTEAD FOR
COMPREHENSIVE UNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS. TO IMPROVE THEIR
TIMING AND BRING OF CUSTOMER.
THEY KNEW TO REACH OUT. REACH
ALL OF THE APPROPRIATE
CUSTOMERS WITHIN THE TIMELINE
SPECIFIED IN THE CURRENT P. S.
P. S. GUIDELINES PUT FORTH BY
THE PC. THEY NEED TO PROVE THEY
USED PS PS AS INDEED A MEASURE
OF LAST RESORT. THESE ISSUES
ALONG WITH OTHERS ARE BEING
ADDRESSED IN EXISTING PSCS
PROCEEDINGS AND WILL BE CENTRAL
TO PLANNING MEETINGS BETWEEN
THE OPERATIONS TEAMS THE CPUC
CALLOW YES CAL FIRE AND THE I.
O. USED I WAS WE PREPARE FOR
THE UPCOMING WELFARE SEASON. WE
ARE ALSO YES THE SCOPE PRIVATE
PARTIES OF EXIST PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT. TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF FUTURE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS FOR EXAMPLE LAST WEEK AT
THE JANUARY SIXTEENTH
COMMISSION MEETING THE CPUC
APPROVED ADDING OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER
FOUR YEARS. TO THE SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
KNOWN AS ASH CHIP WITH 63% OF
THAT FUNDING GORGEOUS OF CLEAN
BACKUP POWER OR VULNERABLE
CUTS. AND IT'LL- STILL IT IS.
THIS FIVE DAY. LITTLES AND
PERSON HOME AREAS ARE MOST. TO
DID BY. IN A THE ENERGY TO BE
RELEASE A PROPOS JUST YESTERDAY
AS PART OF THE MIKE CREDIT AND
REYES PROCEED THAT WILL BE
CRIED TO GET THE MEETINGS WITH
INDIVIDUAL COUNT OFFICE OF
EMERGENCIES. AT EACH ME YOU
WILL BE RE TO SHOW IN ABOUT
ELECT TO AND- FOR STRUCTURE
INCLUDING ANY PLANS HARDENING
IN THAT COUNTY. THERE HAS BEEN
A GREAT ON I OWE YOU BUT ALSO
CREWS. IMPORTANCE TO ENSURING
PUBLIC SAFETY IS THE RESILIENCY
OF SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
THESE MOST RECENT PS THREE PS
EVENTS IN PARTICULAR RESULTED
IN MAJOR IMPACTS TO
COMMUNICATIONS GRID CUSTOMERS
OF ALL SERVICES WERE IMPACT
WHETHER WINT ACTED WHETHER THE
LAND LINE. CABLE V. O. I. P. OR
WIRELESS CARRIERS REPORTED
OUTAGES FOR NEAR. HALF A
MILLION WIRE LINE STEAMER
ALMOST A MILLION WIRE CUSTOMERS.
CELL SITES WERE SERVICE THE
VARIOUS LENGTHS OF TIME AND
WIRELINE. ALSO PARTICULARLY
CABLE PROVIDER. THESE OUT WERE
UNDER. GIVEN THE ASSURANCE THE
COMMUNICATION COMPANIES
PROVIDED TO THE FCC THE STATE
TO YOU THE LEGISLATURE AND TO
THE P. YOU SEE THESE COMPANIES
HAVE OBLIGATION AS WELL AS THE
PRIVILEGE AND RESPONSE. TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS. THE CPUS DE IS
CONSIDERING REQUIRING
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
PROVIDE BACKUP BATTERY POWER
AND GENERATORS AT SELLERS SITES
HARDENING COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REQUIRE AND
COMMUNICATE ITS CARRIERS. HIS
IN PLANNING SIZES WE THE
ELECTRIC I OWE YOU IN IT OF THE
WILD SEASON WE'RE ALSO RECORD
AND THAT THE IDEA USE PROVIDE
BETTER SERVICE. CAPTION TO
ASIAN COME SO THAT MINIMUM
PACKED UP SB PS EVENTS ON THEIR
NETWORK. TO FUND UP BY THE SEA.
FOR WELFARE PREVENT AND SAYS
HARD. PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH THE ESTIMATE PART
OF THE TWO NINE WELL MITIGATION
PLAN. THESE CUSTOM MUST BE UP.
THROUGH EACH YOU TELL GENERAL
K. IN THERE TO NINETEEN DONE M.
P. THE I. O. U. OUTLINE. A NEED
FOR THREE POINT FOUR I'VE THREE
POINT FOUR FIVE BILLION IN
TOTAL AT THE MAJOR KERR ADDICT.
ADDRESS WILDFIRE RISK THE.
ABOUT THEIR CURRENT PROJECTIONS
OUR CALCULATIONS ESTIMATE THAT
FOR EVERY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN W. M. P. WELL FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN SPENDING FOR
EXAMPLE BY P. G. ANY WE CAN
ANTICIPATE APPROXIMATELY AN
EIGHTY DOLLAR ANNUAL INCREASE
IN AVERAGE THE DENTAL BILLS
WHICH IS A SEVEN CENT INCREASE
IN A DENTAL RATE. WE HAVE ALSO
DID THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH
A FEW SLIDES THAT OUTLINED THE
TRANS AN ELECTRIC SYSTEM RATES
FOR YEARS OH FIVE THROUGH
EIGHTEEN WE SEE RATE SPENDING
APART. HISTORICALLY RATE
INCREASES HAVE VERY CLOSELY
TRACKED WITH THE RATE OF
INFLATION BUT AS THE TABLE
SHOWS THAT TRIP HAS NOT HELD
TRUE FOR EXAMPLE WITH S. D. G.
D. SAN DIEGO AND ELECTRIC.
RATES ARE RISING WELL ABOVE THE
OTHER UTILITIES THE CPUC IS
CONCERNED WE WILL SEE SIMILAR
TRENDS BUT OTHER TELL IT SOME
FACTORS LEE. TO THE S. D. G.
ANY INCREASES IN. THE INCREASE
TEST. INTEREST WHICH MAY SENSE
THERE OF THE SIX OH SEVEN YOU.
AND UP I NEED TO MAKE. AS THE
OTHER UTILITY STARTIN BEING OR
DUB M. P. AND THEIR INTO CAN TO
DECREASE AS FOR. THE RATES FOR
CASH TO GO UP AS WELL. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE THIS UP TO
HIGHLIGHT THE RECENT
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SAFETY
POLICY DIVISION AT THE CPUC THE
MAKE THE COMMISSION DECIDED IN
LATE TWENTY NINETEEN TO CREATE
THIS NEW DIVISION TO DEVELOP.
ANALYZE AND ASSIST IN THE
IMPLEMENTING SAFETY POLICIES AS
PART OF OUR REGULATION OF
ELECTRIC GAPS TELECOMMUTE. WHAT
TRANSPORTATION NOBODY'S THE
SAFETY POLICY. DIVISION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR AMONG OTHER
THINGS PERFORMING RISK
ASSESSMENT AND RISK MITIGATION
WITHIN THE UTILITY GENERAL RATE
CASES. I WOULD LIKE TO SHIFT TO
ADDRESS ISSUES RELATED TO THE
PROCUREMENT OF NEW ELECTRIC
GENERATION. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE CPUC STAFF ADJUSTED ITS
ASSUMPTIONS AROUND A
RELIABILITY MODELING AND
DETERMINED THAT THE STATE WILL
NEED ADDITIONAL ELECTRIC
RESOURCES IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE. IN
RESPONSE TO THIS NEW MODEL THE
CPUC ISSUED A RULING REQUESTING
PARTIES COMMENTS AND INPUT ON
NEXT STEPS THIS RESULTED IN A
PROCUREMENT DECISION DIRECTING
ALL LOAD SERVICE PLEASE TO BUY
A- THREE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF NEW RESOURCE TO
BE BROUGHT ONLINE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. SO ALSO RECTOR. A ONE TO
YEAR X. UPPER. OF SOME. GAS
PLANTS THAT WERE SET TO RETIRE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO PROVIDE.
TIME FOR NEW RESOURCES TO
COMPETE TO BE COMPLETED I THINK
YOU ARE BOTH THE CHAIRMAN AND
THE VICE CHAIRMAN MENTION THE
PLANTS EARLIER THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF RESTRICTIONS ON THE
NEW PROCUREMENT SUCH THAT MOST
IF NOT ALL. OF THE NEW RESEARCH
HAS WILL BE RENEWABLE DEMAND
RESPONSE AND BATTERY STORAGE
THE KEY DRIVERS OF THE CHANGE
IN FORECASTING IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WERE THE INCREASE OF
ROOFTOP SOLAR. WHICH HAS PUSHED
THE STATE'S PEAK AND LATER IN
THE DAY WHEN WIND SOLAR ARE NOT
FULLY AVAILABLE. AND IN
ADDITION WE NEED TO REFLECT THE
CHANGING RELIABILITY NEEDS OF
THE STATE DO GREATER
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ONE AND AN
SELLER SOURCES. THE CPUC ALSO
PROVIDE ASSIST TENDS ON HOW
ELECT ISN'T IT IS AVAILABLE TO
IMPORTED INTO CALIFORNIA AS A
SYSTEM TITANS THROUGHOUT THE
WEST THE RETIREMENT OF COAL AND
GAS FIRED SIR. PLANNING SOME
REAP OF IMPORT OF ENERGY AND
THE CAPACITY TO CATER TO
CALIFORNIA WILL BE TWO DID LIKE
NEED BE. TEN FIVE STE IN SHORT
THE CBO DOES NOT BUT THAT IT
CAN RELY ON IN. TO THE EXTENT
IT MAY HAVE IN THE- AN IN A-
THERE WERE SOME UNEXPECTED
UNEXPECTED POWER RESEARCH
RETIREMENTS FURTHER REDUCING
THE RESOURCE AVAILABLE TO MEET
THE STATE'S GREAT LIABILITY
OBJECTIVES. TO RIP THESE FROM A
CURRENT AGAIN THE CPUC HAS
TAKEN THE FOLLOWING STEPS THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCEEDING WILL HAVE AN ON
GOING TRACK THAT IT DID NOT
IDENTIFIES NEAR TERM
RELIABILITY AND NEEDS AN- E. E.
C. THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION CPUC. AND CAL ICE
WHICH YOU'RE- FULLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR MODELING ELECTRIC AND
GENERATION NEED A TRANSMISSION.
WILL CAN YOU WORK TO REFI. THE
MY PROCESS TO BETTER ANTICIPATE
GIFTING NEEDS AND THE GRAD. I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE ENTITIES
CAN ENERGY PER. AS KNOW WE ARE
A LOAD SHIP FROM THE I. O. TO
THE COMMUNITY CHOICE AG. AND
DIRECT ACCESS PROVIDERS CCA
HAVE GROWN RAPIDLY FROM SERVING
ZERO POINT 5% OF THE LOAD IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO SERVE ANY
PROJECTED 29% OF THE LOAD IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MEANWHILE
THE I'LL USE SERVING LOAD HAS
DECREASED FROM 90% TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO A PROJECTED 59% AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. EVEN THOUGH
THE IDEA YOU STILL REPRESENT
60% OF THE DEMAND WE EXPECT THE
CCA'S WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALMOST ALL OF THE NEW
PROCUREMENT OVER THE NEXT FIVE
TO TEN YEARS. THIS IS BECAUSE
THE IOUS HAVE LONG TERM
CONTRACTS FOR MOST OF THEIR
FUTURE NEEDS I ALSO. I WOULD
ALSO I WOULD LIKE ALSO TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON MICHAEL
GRADES SINCE THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT HAS BEEN RAISED A LOT
RECENTLY AS A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION FOR MITIGATING THE
IMPACT OF PS PS EVENTS. THE
CPUC OPEN A NEW RULE MAKING ON
MICHAEL GRIDS AND OTHER
RESILIENCY SOLUTIONS IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE ENERGY DIVISION FORMED A
NEW TEAM DEDICATED SPECIFICALLY
TO MY GROUP IT'S AN TO
RESILIENCY. MID DECEMBER WE AND
CO OPERATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
HOSTED A PUBLIC WORSHIP
WORKSHOP. TO OF DIGNIFIED AND
VET IDEAS FOR SHORT TERM
ACTIONS THAT THE CPUC COULD
TAKE TO ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF MICRO GRIDS AND
OTHER RESILIENCY SOLUTIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY. WE ALSO DIRECTED
STAFF AND THE LARGE I- USED TO
PROPOSE SHORT TERM ACTION
RELATED TO MY COOKING GRIDS
THAT COULD MITIGATE THE IMPACTS
OF PS PS OUTAGES IN TWENTY
TWENTY. STAFF A PROPOSED
EXPEDITING UTILITY APPROVAL OF
THE MICHAEL GRID PROJECTS BY
SIMPLIFYING INTERCONNECTION
APPLICATIONS AND DIRECTING
UTILITIES TO SHARE
INFRASTRUCTURE DATA WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENABLE
COLLABORATIVE PLANNING. OF THE
NEW MICHAEL GRADE AND
RESILIENCY PROJECTS. WE EXPECT
TO CONCLUDE THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE SHORT TERM ACTIONS BY
THIS SPRING. THE OF ADDITION
MICHAEL AND WE- POLICY
INCLUDING THOSE WERE BY SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE IS
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE OVER THE
REST OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. GOING
FORWARD WE NEED TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE DEPLOYMENT
OF MICRO GRIDS AND THEIR
ABILITY TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS
OF PS PS EVENTS ESPECIALLY IN
RELATION TO WHO BEARS THE COST
OF DEPLOYING THESE SYSTEMS AND
WHO BENEFITS. I SHOULD
HIGHLIGHT THE ESPYS THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE WAS EXPLICIT IN
PROTECTING NON BENEFITING RATE
PAYERS FROM PAYING THE COST OF
THE SYSTEM. HOWEVER DESPITE THE
RATIONAL COST CONTAINMENT
APPROACH THERE ARE STILL
ACTIONS AT THE CPUC CAN TAKE TO
FACILITATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
MICHAEL GOODS FOR BENEFITING
THE RATE PAYERS. BEFORE I
CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGH THE
COLLABORATION WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES IN THE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE TO
ACHIEVING OUR AMBITIOUS STATE
CLEAN ENERGY AND G. H. G.
REDUCTION GOALS. WE ARE CURRENT
CURRENTLY COORDINATE THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET GEN THE- AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ON THE SP ONE
HUNDRED JOINT SINCE HE REPORT
WE DO TO YOU THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR. I'M SORRY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE REPORT
WILL BITE SITE ON THE ALLEN
JUST COPPER HE'S OF ACHIEVING
THE TO THIRTY FIVE HELLO SECTOR
GOAL WHEREBY A PERCENT OUR
ELECTRIC RE. SALES ARE SUPPLIED
BY CARBON RESOURCES. LOOKING AT
WHERE WE ARE TO WE HAVE PROVIDE
SLIDES ON THE ELECTRIC SECTOR
IN EMISSIONS. THESE SLIDE SHOW
THAT IN MAY HAVE GONE DOWN IN
THE ELECTRIC. WHICH MAKES 50%
OF THE STAY IN MAY. AS I THINK
YOU WERE WHERE THE STATE HAS
ALREADY MET IT'S TWENTY TWENTY
G. H. G. GOALS AND ALMOST ALL
OF THOSE REDUCTIONS HAVE COME
FROM THE ENERGY SECTOR.
ELECTRICITY SECTOR IS ALSO
ALREADY ON TRACK TO MEET THE
SECTOR GOALS ESTABLISHED BY THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD FOR TWENTY
THIRTY. FINALLY THE COMMITTEE
HAS REQUESTED THAT I'D ADDRESS
THE C. P. UC'S ROLE IN THE ON
GOING P. G. IN A BANKRUPTCY
CASE PLEASE BE PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT I CAN ONLY SAY
SOME LIMITED THINGS. ABOUT THE
BANKRUPTCY BUT I WILL TRY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THAT I HAVEN'T
REPORTED ON. I CAN REPORT THAT
THE CPUC HAS BEEN ACTIVE IN AND
OUTSIDE OF THE COURTROOM. OUR
EFFORTS HAVE FOCUSED ON VARIOUS
INTERESTS AND OBJECTIVES OF
CONCERN TO THE COMMISSION. I
CAN SHARE THAT WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY NEGOTIATED THE
PUBLIC PURPOSE MOTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT LEGISLATIVELY
MANDATED PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO
BE FUNDED. DURING THE CHAPTER
ELEVEN CASES DESPITE THE
AUTOMATIC STAY IMPOSED BY THE
BANKRUPTCY CODE. PROGRAMS
AUTHORIZED BY THE BANK GOT SICK.
TO NOT WITHSTAND THE CHAP
ELEVEN. INCLUDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BIOMASS AND BY A
METHANE PROGRAMS THE ELECTRIC
PROGRAM INFEST INVESTMENT
CHARGE EPIC. WHICH FUNDS OUR
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AN INTERVENOR
COMPENSATION THESE WERE ISSUES
RAISED AS AREAS OF CONCERN. FOR
AIR FOR VARIOUS MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. UNDER BOTH THE
FEDERAL BANKRUPTCY RULES AND AB
TEN FIFTY FOUR THE CPUC MUST
APPROVE THE BANKRUPTCY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AND FIND
THAT IT MEETS SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS. THE MECHANISM FOR
APPROVED AN AGREEMENT WOULD BE
A VOTE. FULL COMMISSION IN A
PROCEEDING THAT GIVES THE
INTERESTED PARTIES. RETURN EVER
ON THE A GROUP. ON SEPTEMBER
SIX TWENTY. THE CBC OPEN THE
FOR PURSE. TO CONSIDER THE RATE
MAY AN OTHER IN OF A PER PLAN
OF REORGANIZATION. SINCE THIS
SEEING MY INDEPENDENT APPROVED
THE PLAN OF REORGANIZATION AND
THE COMMISSIONERS CANNOT COMMIT
TO THEIR FINAL DECISION UNTIL
ALL PARTIES HAVE HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT PRESENT
EVIDENCE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS THE
COMMISSION AS A WHOLE NEEDS TO
KEEP SOME DISTANCE FROM THE
NEGOTIATIONS IN THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT BUT SENIOR STAFF OUTSIDE
COUNSEL AND FIND AN ACTUAL
ADVISORS. HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THE PRECEDING TO HELP AYE
GUIDANCE TO THE COURT AND
INTERESTED PARTIES IN THE
BANKRUPTCY. A CASE THE CPUS
FOCUS FOR ME. ON AND THAT WHILE
FIRE VICTIMS ARE COMPENSATED
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
SAFE AND RELIABLE SERVICE AT
REASONABLE RATES CONSISTENT
WITH ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE HOLES. WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO SPEAK
TO YOU AND TO ALLOW ME TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SUBJECT MATTERS
FACING SEE YOU PC TODAY. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE PREPARED
TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WILL SAY
THAT YOUR PRESENTATION WAS
COMPREHENSIVE IT TOUCHED ON ALL
OF THE AREAS THAT ANCHOR
IMPORTANT. THE CERTAINLY THEY
CAN AT LARGE. TERMS OF AIR
BEFORE. I'M GOING TO TURN TO
MIKE. I HAVE A QUESTIONS BUT
YOU TO MIKE TO MAYBE. AND A
THEN WILL MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS INCLUDED A IS
MEMBER THERE LIKE TO. A DOCTOR
QUIRK. FOR OF ALL WE SHOULD BE.
YOU MAY PRESIDENT WHICH BE
THANK YOU. BECAUSE OF WE KNOW
HOW. JOB SO AT THE P. U. C. K.
BE. AND OF COURSE. YOU JUST GOT
THERE WE SHOULD BE SUPPORTIVE.
OF YOUR EFFORTS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
OUR GENERAL SITUATION I DON'T
KNOW THAT YOU CAN SPEAK TO ALL
OF MY QUESTIONS TODAY BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU COULD
EITHER GIVE US AN ANSWER NOW OR
LATER WOULD BE FINE- I AM
CONCERNED THAT THE P. YOU SEE-
HAS RESERVATIONS ABOUT OPENING
UP A LEASE SO CANYON AGAIN. AND
THE REASON I'M CONCERNED IS
THAT IT COULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON
RELIABILITY OF GAS- BUT ALSO
RELIABILITY OF ELECTRICITY- AND
ALSO AN IMPACT ON COSTS FOR
BOTH GAS AND ELECTRICITY I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE IMPACTS
OUR- BUT I'D BE. FIRST BY
ASKING THAT LOOK AT THOSE
IMPACTS I SHOULD YOU CONTINUE
TO HAVE RESERVATIONS ABOUT
ALLOWING A LEASE CANYON OPEN
AGAIN- DO YOU WISH TO MAKE A
RESPONSE TO THE ISSUES. I'M A
THIRD THANK YOU BURKE I WE HAVE
RECEIVED I RECEIVE I BELIEVE
WAS IN DECEMBER. A LETTER FROM
THE GOV. QUESTION THAT
IMMEDIATELY IN A STUDY. OF A
LEASE CANYON AND AN WE HAVE WE
SECURED THE FUND IN THE BY FOR
THAT AND WE- BEGUN TO AND- THAT
WILL BE A STUD OF THE SAID YOU
JUST OUTLINED SIR OF IS A AND
IN AND THAT BE DONE WHAT THIS
YEAR AND I'M GONNA TO MISTER UP
TO SEE SENATE. HE NEEDS TO ADD.
THANK UP. SOME OF OUR- YEAH I
AS I THINK YOU ARE WHERE WE
HAVE NO PROCEED ON THAT THE
ISSUE. I IT'S PRETTY TO SAY
THAT THE- HAS OF YOU ONE WAY OR
NOW ALL THE TERM A NECESSITY
FOR LEASE SO ALL IF THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT MEASURES CAN BE
TAKEN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL
OFFER TO BE SHUT DOWN- AS-
YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE
LEGISLATION FOR. SEVERAL YEARS
AGO REQUIRES THE COMMISSION- TO
OPEN A PROCEEDING- TO LOOK AT
SPECIFICALLY THE QUESTIONS
YOU'RE ASKING- IN THAT
PROCEEDING IS BEING DRIVEN- IN
LARGE PART BY- CONSULTANT
MODELING- AND THEN MODELING
FROM WITH AND I THINK THE
COMMISSION. TO ASK THAT VERY.
TO IT IS THE QUICKLY FEASIBLE.
FEASIBLE FOR LIABILITY
STANDPOINT THE SHUTDOWN BUT
ALSO ASKING THE OTHER SET OF
QUESTIONS WHICH IS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR UST ASK US TO DO. BOB
IS WHAT. NOT ONLY IS IT FOR DO
BUT IF WE DO DO IT WHAT WOULD
IT TAKE TO DO IT. RIGHT YEAH.
THAT THOSE ARE CERTAINLY GOOD.
AND THEN PLEASE THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE. ARM INFORMED WHICH
I'M SURE HE WANTS TO BE KEPT
INFORMED- EVEN THOUGH HE DOES
GET IS- ELECTRICITY FROM
PASADENA POWER BUT AT ANY RATE
NOW IT JUST TO KEEP HIM
INFORMED AND HE WILL KEEP US
INFORMED WE WILL INDEED THANK
YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT. I CONCERNED.
THE FIRST THING THAT PEOPLE
SAID WHEN THE FOR FIRST OF ALL
WE SHOULD REMEMBER THAT THIS
FIRES GO. THE LAST TIME I HEARD
NUMBERS ON THIS AOUT 7% OF
FIRES ARE STARTED BY UTILITY
WIRES AND ABOUT IT BUT HOWEVER
THEY DO BECAUSE ABOUT 20% OF
THE DAMAGE SO THEIR HEAVY
HITTERS. PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY
START ARE CLOSER TO WHERE THEY
ARE THEY ARE ROUTE THERE ARE
PEOPLE BUT IT'S STILL NOT JUST
SHUTTING OFF POWER IS GOING TO
STOP US FROM HAVING- A
WILDFIRES WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE
THIS FALL THAT WE DID NOT GET A
LOT OF WILDFIRES- I AM WORRIED
THAT THIS AT THAT. FIRST WEEK
CHAIR PNG PAGE IN A AND OTHER
UTILITIES DOWN FOR NOT. DE
ENERGIZING NOW WERE TEARING
THEM DOWN FOR G. ENERGIZING AND
WHILE I REALIZE THAT IT HAS THE
PROBLEMS THAT YOU BROUGHT UP IN
TERMS OF COMMUNICATION. IN
TERMS OF. PROBABLY BE MORE
WIDESPREAD THAT AND HOW TO BE
SIMPLY BECAUSE FRANKLY THEY'RE
LEARNING HOW TO DO IT. DO TO
MAKE. YOU'RE SAYING P. S. P. AS
SHOULD BE THE LAST RESORT THAT
IS THE POWER SHUTDOWNS FIRST
PUBLIC SAFETY- I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
THAT LEAD TO MORE FIRES AND I
THINK WEHAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL WHEN WE SAY THAT THIS
IS THE LAST RESORT AND AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE A- COMMENT THERE. YES
SIR THANK YOU- THIS IS THE MANY
THINGS THAT I HAVE MENTIONED IN
MY TESTIMONY TODAY THAT THE PC
IS UNDERTAKEN. IS OUR ATTEMPT
TO AN OBJECTIVE IS INDEED TO
GET TO. MAY I USE THE WORD MORE
SURGICAL PS PS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE SYSTEMS AND THOSE
THINGS LIKE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT MITIGATION EFFORTS
ARE GETTING TO THOSE THINGS-
THAT WILL INDEED ALLOW THE I.
O. USE TO DO A MUCH BETTER JOB
OF MAKING SURE WHEN THEY DO
PULL THE LEVER. THAT IT IS THE
LAST RESORT ONE OF THE CONCERNS
OF COURSE IS. ABOUT THE DANGERS
OF NOT TURNING OFF THE ENERGY
AND THE DANGERS OF TURNING OFF
THE ENERGY RIGHT THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BALANCE
AND WE WERE LACKEY WE DID HAVE
A OF FIRES THIS FALL- YOU KNOW
THE KINCAID FIRE. WAS QUITE
LARGE AND WAS WITH ONE OF THE
MOST DAMAGING- THANK GOODNESS
WE DID NOT LOSE LIVES THIS
YEAR. BUT THE FEAR WAS THAT-
THE LOSS OF POWER IS ALSO
ENDANGERING OF EOPLE'S LIVES
SO YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
INCREDIBLE CARE THAT THOSE
DECISIONS TO TURN OFF THE POWER
OF THE ELECTRICITY AND WHERE
AND HOW AND THE NOTIFICATION OF
THAT IS DONE EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY WELL. IT WASN'T THIS
YEAR AND THE MANY THINGS THAT I
MENTIONED HERE THAT WE ARE
UNDERTAKING FOR THIS YEAR FIRE
SEASON FROM REGULATORS ARE NOT
KNOWN TO BE NIMBLE. WE'RE GONNA
BE IS AS WEAK AS I CAN MAKE
CUTS FOR THIS FIRE SEASON ON
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
WORKING ON AND WORKING ON A
COMBINED. A COMBINATION WITH-
KALLIO YES AND CAL FIRE AND OUR
OTHER SISTER. AGENCIES THAT
WILL BE INVOLVED. THANK YOU
THAT THAT'S A VERY REASON BY I
WILL SAY I'M- MORE WORRIED
ABOUT WHY THEY- I AM ABOUT. THE
OTHER AND F THERE'S A QUESTION
AND WE HAVE TO DECIDE I'M GOING
TO DECIDE AND I WOULD. URGE YOU
DECIDE IN TERMS OF PREVENTING
FIRES. WELL I WOULD NEVER SPEAK
FOR- TOM PORTER AND CAL FIRE
BUT THERE HAS BEEN GREAT
ADVANCEMENT MADE. IN AS I'M
SURE YOU'RE ALL AWARE IN THIS
LAST FIRE SEASON. OF THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT THEY CAN DO WITH
TECHNOLOGY THEY ARE GETTING
VERY PRECISE IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WEATHER
CONDITIONS. WHAT FOLLOWED FIRE
LOAD OR FIRE- VEGETATION LOAD-
THEY HAVE GREAT MODELING IN
PREVIOUS- WEATHER CONDITIONS
FIRE CONDITIONS. AND CAL FIRES
MAKING AS HIS KALLIO YES MAKING
AND WE ARE TO WE ALL USE IN
SOME OF THE SAME MODELING AND
SOME- SOME OF THE GREAT
TECHNOLOGY. I'M TECHNO SILVERS
OF THE REALLY BECAUSE TO THIS
WAY BUT IT THERE THERE TO A
POINT WHERE WE CAN. REALLY
PRECISE PEOPLE'S. OF EQUIPMENT
UNDERSTANDING EVEN EVEN VERY
QUICK CHANGES IN WEATHER GIVEN
THE TOPOGRAPHIC AREAS THAT HAVE
HAD PREVIOUS TOUGH FIRE
SITUATIONS THIS IS ALL
INFORMING ALL OF US WE WHO ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES. OF HOW
BETTER PREPARE FOR FIRE PREVENT
FIRE FIGHT FIRE. AND HOPEFULLY
ADVISED US IN TERMS OF ANY
POWER SHUT UP SO I THINK BOTH
AREAS OF CONCERN. SHUTTING OFF
THE POWER AND PREVENTING AND
FIGHTING FIRES- WE'RE GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER AT IT YOU SAW
A BIG CHANGE JUST IN LAST YEAR
TO THIS YEAR AND HOW CALIFORNIA
S. AND CAL FIRE. ON WORKED WITH
WITH THE DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
IN THE AND THE FOR. AND
PREVENTING OF FIRE SPREAD
LASTLY I WANT TO GIVE MY
COLLEAGUES A CHANCE TO ASK
OTHER QUESTIONS THOUGH I COULD
PROBABLY KEEP YOU HERE ALL DAY
MY LAST QUESTION IS ON LOOKING
AT THE MICRO GRANTS. I'D ASK
YOU TO PRIORITIZE AREAS WHERE.
WE WON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THE MICROGROOVE STARTING A FIRE
SO WE HAVE TO TURN IT OFF TO.
AND WORKING IN AREAS THAT ARE
LIKELY TO HAVE THOUGH SHUT OFF
AND THEN MAKING SURE- AS HE
SAID ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THE
MICRO GRANT- I'M SURE YOU'LL BE
LOOKING AT THAT AND THAT IS FOR
ME A VERY HIGH PRIORITY THAT
VERY MUCH OF A PART OF THE
PROCEEDINGS. GREAT THANK YOU.
DR THANK YOU. I AND THANK YOU
ED FOR YOUR PRESENTE. AND THANK
YOU I A START WORK SAID. THANK
YOU FOR. TO THIS ON IT IS A-
DEAL ANNA. AND MANY OF US ARE
HAPPY TO SEE A WOMAN SITTING AT
THE TABLE. EVERY SHADE THAT. A
QUESTIONS ONE JUST A MINUTE AND
IT'S A QUESTION I RAISED AS THE
YEARS I'VE BEEN ON THIS. AND WE
PEOPLE KEEP COMING WITH IDEA
THAT GIVE THE P. THIS MORE AND
MORE RESPONSIBILITIES. AS YOUR
AFFECTING- IS YOUR ASSESSING
YOUR ABILITY TO BE NIMBLE WITH
THE CRISIS AT THAT ARE COMING
AND I'LL SAY WE'RE GETTING
BETTER AT FIGHTING WILDFIRES
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE OF THEM
THAT'S NOT A GOOD WAY TO. I
MEAN. IT'S NOT THE MODEL WE
WANT RIGHT. IT WILL YOU ALSO BE
ASSESSING BREAKING IT UP OF BIT
PER NOT TRYING TO HAVE THE SEE
IF YOU SEE BE CHARGED
EVERYTHING THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE A REGULAR. ABOUT
COMPARTMENT A SOME OF THE
AROUND SAFETY AROUND TRY BUT
WHAT IT IS TO THINKING ABOUT
REACHED THE WAY THAT WE HAVE
AND IT'S BEEN STRUCTURED IN
THAT WE'D KEEP THROW MORE MORE
MORE ON YOU AND THEN HOW ARE
YOU ABLE TO BE REALLY GOOD
EVERYTHING RIGHT IF
EVERYTHING'S A PRIORITY NOTHING
IS A PRIORITY THAT THAT'S MY
FIRST QUESTION WHEN I THINK OF
YOU THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN- I'M
THERE'S A LOT ON OUR PLAY RIGHT
NOW AND ON MUCH OF IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE IMMEDIACY OF WHAT
WE'VE JUST BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IN MY TESTIMONY BUT
OUTSIDE OF THAT WE HAVE WATER
AND RAILROADS AND- UBER AND
LIFT AND- MANY OTHER AREAS THAT
ARE CRITICAL. MATTER JUST
CRITICAL AND YOU'VE WELL STATED
THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT THAT HAS
BEEN ASSIGNED OVER THE YEARS TO
THE PC I'M IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT IT AND I THINK
SOME OF YOU. KNOW THAT ONE OF
MY- ONE OF ACTIVITIES THAT I'VE
WORKED HARD ON A PUBLIC SERVANT.
IS TO BRING A MORE OF. NOT
NECESSARILY A FISH BECAUSE I
THINK THAT HAS A NEGATIVE. BUT
MORE EFFECTIVE GOVERNMENT
PROCESSES. AND MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS. HAVE
SPECIFICALLY COMMISSIONER
RANDOLPH AND COMMERCIAL WRECK
SHAMAN HAVE TAKEN ON IN THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF. A EFFORT
TO REFORM OUR- MANY OF OUR
INTERNAL PROCESSES SO I THINK
WE NEED- TO LOOK AT HOW WE HOW
WE DO OUR OWN BUSINESS IF YOU
WELL I'D AND DO A LITTLE BIT OF
BUSINESS RE ENGINEERING WHICH
THEY HAVE. DONE ADMIRABLY AND-
SO I WON'T I CAN'T TAKE CREDIT
FOR THAT WHAT I DO HOPE TO DO
IS TO JOIN THEM IN THEIR
EFFORTS OF MAKING OUR INTERNAL
PROCESSES MORE EFFECTIVE AND
MORE. NUMBER IF I MAY USE A
WORD AGAIN THAT'S I THINK OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS BECAUSE
OF THE ACTIVITIES AS I HAVE
OUTLINED ALONG WITH THE
BANKRUPTCY I WOULD HATE TO
PLEDGE TO YOU. THIS YEAR. ON IN
MY TERM- WHETHER I'M GOING TO
BE ABLE TO TACKLE. REFORM THAT
WOULD GO TO AN ABSOLUTE
REORGANIZATION IN SOME CASES
THAT MAY EVEN TAKE A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT AS
YOU'RE WELL AWARE SO WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THAT BUT I THINK WE
HAVE A GOOD START ON CLEANING
UP. PRIORITIZING SOME REFORMS
WITHIN OUR OWN PROCESSES AND
THAT'S A MORE IMMEDIATE FOCUS
FOR ME. OKAY AND THEN. MY NEXT
I THINK IT'S MORE OF A COMMENT
THERE'S NOTHING MORE MOTIVATING
I THINK IN THE WILD FIRES AND I
HAVE FAMILY POINT MY MOTHER
LIVES IN ORVILLE SO EVERY TIME
THERE IS A HE SHUT DOWN I MEAN
THEY ARE AFFECTED AND I HEAR
ABOUT IT ANY WORK IN THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY. SO I'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THAT AS WE SO THEN MY
GUESS MY OTHER POINT M. AND
I'LL SAY BUT THE IT IT IS IT
CREATES ANXIETY AS YOU WELL
KNOW ALL ACROSS THE STATE IS
NOT JUST PEOPLE LIVE IN FIRE.
HI FIRE AREAS THE TREE DOWN TO
EVERYBODY WORRYING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IF IT'S US WE'RE ON OUR
CHEN MY- MEAN WE- IT. THROUGH
THE SUMMER I THINK ANY OF US TO
A COMMUNITY MEETING TOWN HALL
OF QUANTUM CLUB BUT WE WEREN'T
ABOUT GINNY HOW FIRES AND
ALMOST. THAT'S THE ENVY. YEAH
NOT THE DAY OF EATING RISK THAT
OFF LIST THANK. AT BUT THEN THE
OTHER THING IN. WHEN WE'RE AT
AND THEN I PARKED ON THIS ABOUT
I ALSO CHAIR THE GUY WHO
COMMITTEE AND I LIVE REPRESENT
STOCKINGS JOAQUIN. AREABUT
JUST THE ID OF OUR TECH. THAT
ALSO TAKE CARE SOME OF OUR
WASTE CAUSES OUR FIRE AND
CONTRIBUTE THE DECLINE OUR AIR.
ALL NEEDS TO BE A CAN. WE WANT
TO IS CLEANER WE CAN. BUT WE
NEED CLEAN UP OUR FOR AND WE
NEED TO HAVE WAYS OF BEING ABLE
TO THAT. BIOMASS BIO BECAUSE
WHATEVER THAT IS AND FOREST
AREAS AND ANY TO BE THE IN. AND
TO BE ABLE TO THAT SO IF YOU
KNOW SOMETHING AS MULTIPLE BEEN.
AND I WE SHOULD AT IT WITH
DIFFERENT LINE. WAS DRIVING OUT
EAST OF STOCK. WE OUT TOWARDS
LINDEN NEW VERY HIGH HEAVY. AND
PEOPLE ARE OPEN BIRD RIGHT THEY
HAVE NO OTHER. TO DO. A BREATHE
RIGHT BECAUSE IT YOUR THE FOG
HOLDING DOWN THERE PEOPLE ARE.
IN THE FIELD BECAUSE I THE
OPTION NAY A POINT. AT WHICH
DOES NOT HELP US IN OUR GOALS
SO JUST. YOU KNOW. I THE
COMMONSENSE APPROACH AND HOPE
SEE A WHOLE MORE OF IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK MISSION UP.
I WANTED BOB ALLY MY COMMENTS
WITH MA'AM QUIRK AND WITH MY
EGGMAN OB A OF THE SIMILAR
CONCERN OF MISTER IN A LOT OF
THE SIMILAR OB TO AS- AG WITH
WITH RESPECT TO THE CONCERT. OF
THE WILD THE SHOT DOWNS ON MY
DAUGHTERS IN LAW TWO OF OUR
FOUR GRAND LIVE IN NORTH FOR.
AS WE'VE HAD OUR SHARE OF THREE
AND FOUR NIGHT IT'S WHEN THEY
STAYED WITH US INSTEAD OF FOR
DOWN THE VALLEY. BUT I WANTED
IT. MAKE THIS UP AND ASK MAY
BEFORE. A COMMENT BECAUSE. WE
ARE WOULD WE ARE FOCUSED HERE
ON G. H. OUR IMAGE IF YOU LOOK
AT CHARTS BY CATEGORY AND ALL
OF THAT. WHICH BASICALLY SAYS
GHGS HAVE BEEN COMING DOWN. IN
THIS ANALYSIS. THE EMISSIONS OF
GHGS OF CARBON BY THE FOREST
FIRES ARE NOT COUNTED. IT'S MY
ESTIMATION THAT IF WE DID COUNT
THE FOREST FIRES. WE WILL BE
BLOWN A HOLE IN THESE MEGA
EMISSION REDUCTIONS SO WE'RE
BASICALLY PRETENDING. THAT WITH
ALL OF THE DECISIONS ON ALL OF
THE- RULES REGULATIONS AND THE
BILLS PASSED ON ALL OF THAT.
WHEN POINT OF FACT. THESE
FOREST FIRES AND WHAT THEY ARE
DOING TO GHG EMISSIONS IS
SIMPLY BLOWN A HOLE. AT THE END
AND I THINK- WE PROBABLY HAVE
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS A
NET INCREASE OF GHG EMISSIONS.
IS THERE ANY EFFORT TO TRY AND
TRACK AND SOMEHOW INTEGRATE
INTO THESE. REDUCTIONS THE GHG
EMISSIONS OF THESE POOREST
BUYERS. I IT'S AN EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT QUESTION AN EXCELLENT
POINT AND I HAVE SEEN
STATISTICS WELL BEFORE I JOINED
THE CPUC ABOUT WHAT THE FOUGHT
WILD FIRES AND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN DID JUST TO THAT AND
WHAT. IT ADDED TO- TO THE G. H.
G. IN IN TERMS OF CALIFORNIA
VERSUS TAKING SO MANY CARS OFF
THE HIGHWAY OR BRINGING ON SO
MANY ELECTRIC CARS DO YOU DO
YOU WANT TO SEE SOME
SPECIFICALLY. I WOULD I JUST
GOT SAID THAT'S REALLY THE
QUESTION FOR THIS IS NOT THE
DOCTOR BUT FOR A RESOURCE BOARD
ON THE SLY THAT WE IF YOU'LL
NOTE THE ARE ALL FOR THE AIR RE
BOARD AND I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US UP ARE- TAIJI ACCOUNT
SCIENCE. I DO KNOW THAT
TRACKING THE WILD FIRED
MISSIONS RELATIVE TO OTHER ONES
IS NOT A STRICT ONE FOR ONE
ANALYSIS- BECAUSE OF THE
ABILITY OF THE FOREST TO BE A
CARBON SINK ON IN BECAUSE THE
TIMING IN WHICH THE FORESTRY
GROWS AND IN WHICH IT WAS THE
SAME TO START IT YOU HAVE TO DO
A MUCH DEEPER ALICE SAID IF I
GO FURTHER THAN THAT. YOUR I
MEAN I SHOW THAT'S INTO MY NOW
ON THAT OTHER THAN THE POINT
BACK TO THE AIR BEES ON
ANALYSIS TO ADDRESS WAS QUITE
BUT I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM AT
ALL IN. IN THAT DAY WITH THEIR
I THINK IT I TO SOME SOME IT
INTERESTING IN HOW WE TO THE
ONE FOR ONE OR THE COMPARISONS
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
TO LET YOU KNOW AND I THINK
IT'S VERY I THINK IT'S REALLY.
QUITE IMPORTANT BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD. BE PRETENDING.
AND QUITE FRANKLY THE- FIRES
ARE IN. I THINK CONTRIBUTING SO.
AT WE ARE RE. A PARTICULAR IN
AGRA PART IN. AND ALL. THE
ELECTRICITY RATES AND THE
REGULATORY STUFF IS REALLY
DRIVING COSTS UP IT'S QUITE
FRANKLY DRIVING A LOT OF-
ORGANIZATIONS OUT OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE
COST FACTOR IN ALL OF THAT. MY
POINT IN THIS IS THAT. TO KNOW
THE DEGREE TO WHICH- THE FOREST
FIRES. PUSH THE G. H. G. UP.
WHILE WE'RE TRYING TO REDUCE IT
I THINK BEGS THE QUESTION THAT
IF WE'RE GOING TO USE THE GHG
FUNDS. THAT SO MUCH OF THOSE
FUNDS OUGHT TO BE DEDICATED TO
FORCE MANAGEMENT AND TO GETTING
THESE FOREST'S- CLEANED UP SEND
THE FUEL STE BROUGHT DOWN. AND
I'M NOT IF I HAD MY WAY I'D
DIED USE EVERY PENNY. QUITE
FRANKLY THIS IS THE CHALLENGE
NOT ONLY OF THE FOREST FIRES
COST AND DANGER IT IS ALSO
BASICALLY MASKING. ARE THE REAL.
THAT HAVE BEEN THAT MADE AND
CARBON. SO I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE PAT OURSELVES ON THE
BACK FOR THESE REDUCTIONS WHEN
IN FACT WE SEE. ARE THAT THEY
ARE EXPLODING. THAT'S TRUE WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON GAGE AND
ASSESS IT. THEN WE CAN MAKE
REALLY GOOD INFORMED DECISIONS
WITH RESPECT OF WHAT DO WE DO
WITH THESE GHG. FUNDS AND WHAT
DO WE DO WITH THESE OTHER.
ABILITY OF- BIOMASS IN THESE
OTHER. KINDS OF SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND NOT.
APPRECIATE THAT WHATEVER YOU
MIGHT HAVE SAY WITH. TO THAT
OUT I KNOW THAT THEIR PROBABLY
DIFFICULT TO ACCOUNT FOR. BUT
CALIFORNIA DOES. ACCOUNT FOR A
LOT OF THIS AND WE BELIEVE IT
AS GOSPEL. I'M NOT CONVINCED
THAT WE CAN BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
REDUCING GHG IF WE DON'T
ACCOUNT FOR FOREST FIRES AND
THAT'S GOING TO INFORM OUR
DECISIONS WITH RESPECT GHG
FUNDS THAT WE SPEND. I'M
REMINDED THAT ARE WILDFIRES
STRATEGIES AND CAROLINE CAN
ADDRESSES TAKE IN TO ACCOUNT-
CLIMATE GOALS WHICH OF COURSE
INCLUDES THE GHG. COUNTY ONE OF
AND THEN SEAT ANYTHING FURTHER
ON THAT SURE SO ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DID RESEARCH ON OUR
CURRENT STATE WAS AND WHAT BEST
PRACTICES WERE ACROSS THE GLOBE
ON UTILITY IGNITED WILD FIRE
MITIGATION EFFORTS- AND DEVELOP
THE NEW OUT FOR MITIGATION
GUIDELINES A MATURITY MODEL WE
ALSO STARTED DRAFTING OUT THE
FOR- GOALS DRAFT GOALS FOR. HOW
DO WE BALANCE THOSE COMPETING
NEEDS SO WHAT WHAT ARE WE
DRIVING TOWARDS AND WE CREATED
A STEERING COMMITTEE TO INFORM
ALL OF THAT WORK AND IT'S
INCLUSIVE OF THE FOREST-
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE THE
ENERGYCOMMISSION CALLAWAY ASK
CAL FIRE US- AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND ALL OF THOSE
DELIVERED OF DISCUSSIONS ARE
HAPPENING. AT THAT LEVEL RIGHT
NOW WE'RE TRYING TO DECIDE OF
HOW DO WE START THE BOUNCE THAT
SO THAT WHEN WE COME OUT THE
STRATEGY IN THE ROAD MAP THAT
WE CAN HAVE SOME TARGETS WERE
BACK IN THOSE DIFFERENT F.
INCLUDING. THE IN TERMS OF HOW
TO USE FILE TO. I'M YOU KNOW
LEVERAGE ALL RESOURCES APPROACH.
IT IN THE TO RID OF FIRE REST
CAUSED BY. RECREO IF I DIE.
BECAUSE OF YOUR AND YOUR NAME
BUT THE DOCTOR WAS REALLY HAD A
ON THIS TOP ON THIS PER. POINT
WHEN IT YEAH SO THE EMISSION
EACH YEAR ARE OF WHILE. ARE THE
PEAK IT'S TYPICALLY AROUND TWO.
ARE. WHAT IS IT MILLION YEAH
MILLION METRIC TONS. ARE PEAK
YEARS LIKE TWENTY OR FOR FIVE.
UP FOR FIVE IS A WHAT THE ELECT
SECTOR PRODUCE. AN IT'S ABOUT
ONE TENTH OF THE TOTAL WE- SO
THE TWO YOU. IT'S ABOUT FIVE
PER OF GREEN GAS CHEN. AND
TYPICALLY ABOUT HALF WHAT THE
YOUTH GENERATE. WHICH IS A LOT
FOR. THIS CARILLO YOUR YOUR
NEXT AND SCORE SIERRA AND
INVESTMENT RESEARCH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF AND
AGAIN WELCOME PRESIDENT BADGER
AND YOUR TEAM FOR BEING WITH
US- TODAY I TWO QUESTIONS ONE
HAVING TO DO WITH THE NET
ENERGY METERING PROGRAM THE
SECOND FOLLOWED BY A QUESTION
RELATED TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WHICH IS- MY PROVIDER
AND A PORTION OF MY DISTRICT.
BUT FIRST I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY
THAT I'M EXCITED TO READ THE
REPORT SB ONE HUNDRED PORT-
THAT HE WILL PROVIDE TO US IN
EARLY JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR YES
WHICH WILL BE AROUND THE CORNER
BEFORE WE KNOW IT- SOL STARTED
BY SAY THAT SEVEN YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AB THREE
TWENTY SEVEN BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PARADE AT WHICH
AMONG OTHER THINGS CALLED FOR
THE COMMISSION TO COMPLETE. A
STUDY ON THAT ENERGY METERING
OR ANY M. VISIT ANY OF OUR NAM
AND ANY- OR NAM EITHER ANY I.
YEAH RIGHT THE LAW ALSO WERE
THE YOU SEE TO ENSURE THAT THE
FULL OF SERVICE PROVIDE BY
PROVIDED TO ANY AND CUSTOMERS
ARE PAID BY THOSE CUSTOMERS AND
THAT THE COSTS ARE NOT SHIFTED
TO KNOCK ON ANY M. CUSTOMERS
WHILE THE COMMISSION MADE SOME
CHANGES. ANY AT PRO THEY ALSO
COMMITTED TO RIVAS THIS IS LAST
YEAR. AND TWENTY NINE WHICH HAS
THE TO TAKE PLACE. SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU PRESIDENT
BADGERS GIVEN THAT THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED TWO
BILLION DOLLARS STATEWIDE.
KASHIF DISASSOCIATED WITH THE
ANY AND PROGRAM WHAT IS THE
COMMISSION'S PLAN FOR
ADDRESSING. THIS ISSUE IN THE
TIMELINE FOR OPENING A
PROCEEDINGS AND ADDRESSING THAT
SIGNIFICANT COST SHIFT ISSUE.
I'M GOING TO TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER RANDOLPH TO
ANSWER THAT IF I MAY. BUT IN
TERMS TO THE TIMING IN THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DATE- WHEN
THE COMMISSION HAD- APPROVED
WHAT WE CALLED IN AND TWO POINT
NO- WHICH WAS IN RESPONSE TO.
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION IN SB
THREE TWENTY SEVEN. WE HAD AND
COME TO DO A REVIEW. OF THAT
DECISION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. BOB THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TIMING- WAS BASED ON
THE FACT THAT IN THAT SAME.
SERIES OF DECISIONS THE
COMMISSION HAD ALSO- DIRECTED
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
MOVE TO- PARADIGM OF TIME OF
USE RATES FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. AND WE THOUGHT THE
BEST TIMING FROM BOTH THE
CUSTOMER AND TAX AND POINT IN
AND- ANALYTICAL STANDPOINT WAS
TO LET THE TIME OF USE RATES
ROLL OUT FOR. UNDER THE IMPACT
OF THE THEN REVISIT NET ENERGY
METERING AND THAT THAT'S VERY
FOR AN AND STAY. BECAUSE COST
SHIFT THAT YOU REFERENCED WHICH
THAT NUMBERS FROM- GOV FAIRLY
OLD STUDY- WITH BASED ON THE
OLD RATE STRUCTURE- IN THAT
RATE STRUCTURE WILL CHANGE. IN
THE COST IMPACTS OF KNIT OF NET
ENERGY METERING WILL CHANGE
WHEN CUSTOMERS MOVE FROM- A
TIERED RATE STRUCTURE WHICH
THEY WERE ON TO THE TIME OF USE
RATE STRUCTURE. WHAT'S HAPPENED
BOB WELL SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IS
SEND YOUR GAS ELECTRIC IS NOW
IN THE PROCESS OF MOVING THAT
TIME OF USE RATES- THE OTHER
TWO WERE DELAYED- BECAUSE THE
COMPUTER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
NEEDED- TO PROVIDE GOOD BILL
INFORMATION TO THE CUSTOMER'S.
EXPRESSION THAT FIRST YEAR
BECAUSE THE UTILITIES ARE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO DO SHADOW
BUILDING WHERE EACH MONTH
YOU'RE GOING TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
BILL IS ON TIME OF USE RATES
AND THEN YOU WOULD KNOW WHAT IT
IS ON THE OLD RATE STRUCTURE.
AND AT THE END OF THAT FIRST
YEAR IF YOUR RATES WOULD HAVE
BEEN LOWER ON THE OLD RATE
STRUCTURE GOING TO BE REFUNDED
THE DIFFERENCE I'M ALL THAT
REQUIRES. FAIRLY UP TO DATE CAN
JUST SO THE SAN DIEGO IS READY
TO GO THE OTHER. UTILITIES NEED
TO UPGRADE THEIR- OVERALL FOR A
BUNCH OF REASONS- THEIR
COMPUTER SYSTEMS. I'M IN SO WE
DECIDED THE WISE THING TO DO
WAS TO WAIT UNTIL THOSE
UPGRADES ARE IN PLACE. BEFORE
THEY ROLL OUT THEIR TIME OF USE
RATES ALL THEIR CUSTOMERS
THAT'LL HAPPEN WITH P. JEANNIE
EACH CUSTOMER'S. STARTING THIS
FALL. AND THEN IT WILL HAPPEN-
WITH A SMALL SEGMENT OF EDISON
CUSTOMERS ALSO STARTING THIS
FALL. AND THEN THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY REQUESTED A ANOTHER
DELAY FOR I BELIEVE NINE
MONTHS- DUE TO SOME ISSUES
WITH- THERE- UPGRADES OF THEIR-
BACK OFFICE SYSTEMS. BOB I.
WOULDN'T SAY ONCE THAT'S DONE
WE WILL START THE. HEY WE DON'T
CALL HIM POINT OH BUT FOR ONE
OF A BETTER TERM. THE NAMES
POINT NO PROB WE ARE WAIT THEN
WE WERE ALREADY HAVE GONE OUT
OF COMMON. ON WHAT SCOPE- COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS SHOULD LOOK
AT- FOR THIS NEXT STUDY SO
WE'RE STARTING TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THAT THE NEXT
PROCESS- BUT THE TIMING OF THAT
IS GOING TO PROBABLY BE TIED TO
SOME EXTENT- TO WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF TIME OF
USE RATES. THANK YOU ARE IT'S
ALWAYS INTEREST TO THE- THINK
ABOUT IT THROUGH THE
PERSPECTIVE OF COMPUTER SYSTEMS
GIVEN THE- TECHNOLOGY IS PRETTY
MUCH INVENTED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YET WE HAVE.
UTILITIES THE. ARE WE TAKING A
LONG TIME TO GET UP TO DATE
I'LL BE BLUNT. IT FEELS
SOMETIMES LIKE SOME OF THE
UTILITIES COMPUTER SYSTEMS ARE
STILL ALL OPERATED ON PNEUMATIC
TUBES AND DURABLES RUNNING ON
WHEELS- THERE IN THE STORE NEED
MASSIVE UPGRADES SO THAT'S PART
OF THE CONVERSATION THAT WE
NEED TO BE HAVING AS THE
BACKEND INFRASTRUCTURE AS TO
HOW WE GET TO WHERE WE NEED TO
THAT OF A CRITICAL PART OF THE
CONVERSATION EXCELLENT. I ALSO
SAW THAT IN THE IN THE
SITUATION THIS FALL WITH P.
JEANNIE. RIGHT WHEN COME.
ABSOLUTELY CRAP. WELL SYSTEMS
PRESIDENT BETTER I AM NEW
MEMBER TO ASSEMBLY STARTING MY
THIRD YEAR. AND YOUR NEW TO
YOUR PER. SO I. I LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING TO YOU AND YOUR- FOR
THE P. YOU SEE SO THAT WE CAN
WORK TO OUR A ADDRESS THE NEEDS
THAT ARE MOST CRITICAL ALL CAL.
SO MY SECOND QUESTION IS
RELATED TO SOMETHING EDISON
WHICH PROPOSED AN INVEST OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WILD FIRE
RISK MITIGATION MEASURES AND
CLAIMS THAT APPROVAL OF THIS
REQUEST WILL HELP ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S. INCREASE IN VIRUS
BY FURTHER HARDENING THEY GOT
ELECTRICAL SYSTEM ENHANCING
UTILITY SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
AND OPERATIONAL CAPABILITIES.
IN JULY. PARTIES TO THE
PROCEEDINGS SUBMITTED UPPER. SO
TO A THE APPLICATION WITH
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
COST RECOVERY METRICS
REPORTING. ANOTHER RATE PAYER
PROTECTIONS THE OFFICE OF
SAFETY ADVOCATES OPPOSE THE
PROPOSAL SETTLEMENT. THE P. UC
CONTINUES TO CONSIDER THE
PROPOSAL SETTLEMENT AND
MODIFICATIONS RECOMMENDED BY
OSA. WHEN CAN WE EXPECT SOME
ACTION FROM THE COMMISSION ON
THE GREAT SAFETY AND RECENTLY
PROGRAM SETTLEMENT. ON THE
SETTLEMENT I DON'T KNOW A THE
TIME OF THAT IS TO YOU OR BOB.
ON WELL AWARE OF THAT A WITH
ENERGY DIVISION ON WHY AWARE OF
IT'S BUT IT'S THERE FOR A WHILE
THE UTILITY IS ALLOWED TO
TRACTORS COSTS IN WHAT'S CALLED
A MEMORANDUM ACCOUNT- SO IF THE
YOU COMMISSION ULTIMATELY
DETERMINES THAT THERE'S A
REGIONAL COSTS OR COVER THEM-
AND WE ARE AT THIS POINT-
TRYING TO. ADD HAD SEPARATE
PRIORITIZED AND KIND OF WORK
THROUGH WATER THE CRITICAL
DECISIONS WE NEED TO DO ON EACH
ONE- I CAN REPORT BACK- ON WHAT
WE THINK THE EXPECTED TIME
MINUTES AT THIS POINT AND ALL I
CAN SAY IS I'M I'M AWARE OF IT
IS SOMETHING WE'RE TRYING TO
GET. HIGHER ON THE LIST AND
WE'LL BE HAPPY. TO REPORT BACK.
TO YOU. NOW THANK YOU. GARCIA I
THANK YOU SO I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT A THIS ARE ON WILD
AND RIGHTFULLY SO AND IN THIS
AND IN THE CAPITALIST MENISCUS
FROM OLD YEARS BUT THE C. PIECE
HAS A LOT MORE THAN YOU HAVE TO
ON RIGHT IT'S PART OF THE OF
WITH MISSED A MAY WAS REMINDING
US ABOUT INSULT TO ME P. FIVE.
I ONLY HAVE. YOU BILL ABOUT
SAILOR YEAR ASKING YOU TO TASK.
AND TO DISCLOSE AND- QUALIFY IN
THE BILL WE HOPE TO IT'S ALSO
YOU KNOW THEY TAKING THIS TO
CLEAN IT UP. I TO ENSURE THAT
FOREVER THIS STAND A WATER SOME
KEEP RECORD. SAFE OUT THERE AND
SO THE WHY BOARD IS WORKING ON
THE FROM FOSSEN THERE'S AN OVER
THIRTY BETWEEN THE BOARD TO
WORK AND THIS. ON AND SO I YOUR
UP WHEN THEY'RE ANY IT HAD A-
TO LOOK INTO AND WHAT TYPE OF.
YOUR DOING WHAT THE WATER ON
THIS ISSUE. SINCE AN OVERLY
BETWEEN THIS. AND THE WATER
BOARD THERE. ARE YOU CAUGHT ME
TOTALLY BUT A I DO KNOW
ANYTHING OF THAT SO. I'M SO
SORRY AND I. CAN THAT. YEAH NOT
SO IN IT MAY I A GET A- MANY
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU I'M NOT
GOING TO BE UPSET THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A- OF IT TO DAVE I
GUESS. WE CAN WIN FOR LOOK AND
THAT AND- INSURING FROM THAT WE
HAVE COMMUNITY ARE SAY I HAVE
COMMUNITY WHERE EVERY SINGLE AS
CAN. WITH THIS FOREVER WHICH
MEANS THAT I NEVER BREAKS DOWN
AND IT'S CAN OF YOU KNOW THAT
IS CARCINOGEN AT DID A HAVE THE
UP TO STERN THE WALL GO TO
ANOTHER WELL. AND SO WE DO HAVE
YOU. THAT ARE TRYING TO
RESPONSE. IN THE AREA BUT THEIR
TRANSFER HOW DO PAY FOR THIS
AND WHAT DO AND YOU KNOW I NINE
THAT THEY'VE IN LIKE TO SEE.
AND SAYS FROM EVERYTHING MAKING
SURE THE WHILE WE'RE DO THEM
WORK ON WILDFIRES WE DON'T
FORGET ABOUT ALL THE OTHER WORK
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE DOING.
STUFF TIED TO P. FIVE ABS IT'S
JUST HARD TO KNOW THIS OF. HAS
A OR A HUNDRED. SO I'M- I'M
WELL AWARE AND CONCERNED AS A
FELLOW CALIFORNIAN. OF THE OF
THE SERIOUS NATURE. OF MANY OF
OUR OUR- QUALITY WATER AND LESS
THAN SYSTEMS SO. WE WILL LOOK
INTO THIS AND GET BACK AND I'M
EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT I WAS
NOT AWARE OF IT. IT TOOK A AND
SO I MEAN AND THAT'S A VERY
SPECIFIC BUT JUST IN GENERAL AS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT REFORMS THAT
MAYBE HE DID NOW INTERNALLY
RIGHT AS YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE- WELFARE CRISIS AT THE SAME
TIME- THAT WE LOOK AT HOW WE
COULD BE- I THINK YOU SAID MORE
EFFECTIVE. IN OUR COORDINATION
A MORE NIMBLE AND ACCORDING
SEEN WITH OTHER AGENCIES. SO
THAT WERE NOT BEING DUPLICATIVE
US SO THAT WE- SO THAT WE
AGENCIES AREN'T WORKING- IN AN
A- IN. IN THEIR OWN LITTLE
SILOS SILO RIGHT IN AND THAT WE
ARE MAXIMIZING. RESOURCES WHAT
THE HUMAN CAPITAL BUT AND
DOLLARS OUT THERE SO I COULDN'T
THANK YOU AND- I WILL BE
PATIENT APPRECIATE- NEED YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU. YOU SOMERS WHICH- THE
THANK YOU. WELCOME HI WHAT'S ON
MY CALLER AND WELCOMING YEAH
YOU AND YOUR TEAM- LIKE THE-
REST MY COLLEAGUES- WILD FIRES-
HAS. DOMINATED MY- ATTENTION
ESPECIALLY DURING THE FALL BUT
EVEN THOUGH I REPRESENT TO. THE
SOUTH BAY AREA OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- EDISON TERRITORY- I WAS
FOLLOWING AND HEARING FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN TERMS
OF- THE- THE BLACKOUTS AND I
AND SO WHEN I CAME BACK HERE IN
JANUARY I EXPECTED TO SEE AND
HEAR OF A SLEW OF BILLS. YOU
KNOW TO PROPOSAL- A WIDE RANGE
OF- OF MEASURES TARGETING P.
GINNY ARM YOU KNOW ANYTHING
FROM A STATE TAKEOVER OF PIGEON
TO- THE- PIECEMEAL MINUTES
MINUTES BILL IS A SIN OF A OF A
OF A OF UTILITIES TO- YOU KNOW
EVEN MORE TARGETED- PROPOSALS
LIKE PUBLIC- TAKEOVERS OVER
OVER THAT THE TRANSMISSION
LINES- AND SO FORTH BUT- IT
COULD YOU GET A GIVE AN
OVERVIEW AS TO. YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT CONVERSATIONS THEY THEY
THE PC HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN IN
A TO DATE IN TERMS OF. OF
EXPLORING OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC
ALTERNATIVES TO THE P. JEANNIE.
ARE I MENTIONED GIVEN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS AND ALL
THAT'S GOING ON I YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND. NON IF YOU MAY BE
CONSTRAINED FROM. FROM OPENLY
SPECULATING BUT I WAS WONDERING
IF YOU IF YOU CAN GIVE US A
SENSE AS TO WHAT KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS THE PC HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN IN TERMS OF
EXPLORING PUBLIC ON
ALTERNATIVES TO P. JEANNIE I
YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT SIR I
CANNOT SPECULATE ON IT AS A
VOTING MEMBER OF THE PC I DO
KNOW THAT- STAFF HAS MET WITH
SOME OF THE- DIFFERENT
MUNICIPALITIES THAT HAVE IDEAS
AND HAVE PLANS- ADD YOU CAN
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THIS- WE
CAN'T GO INTO GREAT DETAIL. BUT
PROBABLY AS MUCH AS WE CAN
EXPRESS IS WHAT YOU'VE PROBABLY
READ IN THE IN THE PRESS
FRANKLY BUT- YEAH I MEAN IT
JUST. I MEAN WHAT'S IN THE
PRESS IS WHAT I KNOW AS WELL AS
THERE'S BEEN VARIOUS PROPOSALS
OUT THERE FROM VARIOUS FOLKS-
FOR EITHER YOU KNOW MISSILES
ATION OF THE ENTIRE UTILITY
OBVIOUSLY SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO AND SOME OTHER LOOK
AT LOCALITIES WOULD LIKE TO- BY
THE UTILITY SERVICES THERE- YOU
KNOW I THINK THE P. UC'S ROLE
OR NOT I THINK WITH UC'S ROLE
WITHIN ALL OF THAT. I A IS
CLEARLY DEFINED BY STATUTE IN
IT REALLY DEPENDS UPON. THE
MECHANISM IN WHICH THEY FOLLOW
SO OUR ROLE WOULD BE TO BE AN
ADVOCATE FOR OR AGAINST IT
WOULD BE TO FOLLOW THE
STATUTORY GUIDELINES- WHICH
GENERALLY ARE SET UP TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CUSTOMERS ARE
LEFT BEHIND ARE PROTECTED. SO
THAT'S BEEN OUR CONVERSATIONS
ALONG THE WAY IS TO PROVIDE-
PARTIES THAT HAVE PROPOSALS OUT
THERE- THE ROAD MAPS THEY WOULD
NEED TO FOLLOW. UP OKAY. I CAN
RECALL I BELIEVE OUR FIRST
HEARING THE LAST YEAR- WAS WITH
YOUR PREDECESSOR AND- I
REMEMBER REMEMBER ONE OF THE
MAIN TAKEAWAYS THAT AND THAT I-
WALKED AWAY FROM THE HEARING
WAS TO. IS SAYS STATEMENTS-
DESCRIBING HOW WOEFULLY- UNDER.
RESOURCE THE PC IS IN AND IN
TERMS OF ITS- WHAT FIRE SAFETY
OF ENFORCEMENT. EFFORTS COULD
YOU SHARE WITH US YOUR YOUR
OPINION AS TO. WHETHER THEY ARE
THE WILD FIRES- SAFETY
DIVISION- IS- HAS AN ANSWER
RESOURCES TO WELL M. WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THE TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND- ONE ELEVEN LAST SUMMER THE
TRAILER BILL- THE WELFARE
SAFETY DIVISION WAS ESTABLISHED
AND INDEED THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET APPROPRIATED EACH WITH
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
LEGISLATION IT WAS
APPROPRIATED- THAT IT WOULD BE
STAFFED WITH APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO STAFFWHICH CAROLINE HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING TO REALLY
RECRUIT TERRIFIC PEOPLE. AND WE
HAVE A VERY IMPRESSIVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT WILL HAS ALSO
ALSO BEEN ESTABLISHED AND AS I
SAID IN MY TESTIMONY JUST MET
FOR THE FIRST TIME YESTERDAY I
FEEL THAT IN THE DIVISION. WE
ARE ADEQUATELY RESOURCE WE ALSO
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET HAVE-
PROPOSED FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR OUR SAFETY AND
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WHICH I
THINK PRESIDENT PICKER WAS
PROBABLY ALSO REFERRING TO IN
HIS TESTIMONY SO WE DO HAVE ON.
IT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OUR
BUDGET IS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE NOW FOR APPROVAL.
SO I THINK OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS WILL WERE WELL
ACCEPTED AND I THINK WELL
STAFFED AND ARE ASKING FOR AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED. ALL
RIGHT THERE'S NO ENOUGH FREEZER
IT IN NO YOU'LL HEAR THAT FROM
EVERY AGENCY IN GOVERNMENT
SURE. OKAY. MOVING ON TO THE PS
PS ARM. I THINK UGH- MISTER
QUIRK- THANK GOD FOR. THE FEWER
WILD FIRES THAT WE HAD TO THE
THAT THIS FALL BUT TO. THE TWO
TO WHAT EXTENT- WHERE THE P. S.
P. S. WAS THE PS PS- GOT A
PROGRAM- YEAH- KOENIG CLAIM
CREDIT FOR THE FEAR WHAT FIRES.
CAN I I'M SORRY IT CAN PLAGUE
CLAIMED CREDIT FOR THAT WHAT TO
WHAT EXTENT- DID THE P. S. P.
S. BLACKOUTS CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FEAR Y. FOUGHT WILD FIRES FEW
AROUND CLASS YES SIR- I WOULD
REALLY WANT THAT THAT QUESTION
IS BETTER POST I THINK TO THE
I. O. U.'S. BUT THEY CERTAINLY
HAD- REPORTS TO US THAT THEY
THEY HAD POSSIBLE IGNITION
SITES THAT DID NOT IGNITE. AND
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE STATISTICS
RIGHT NOW BUT EACH ONE OF THE I
A IS- SHOWED SIGNS. WHERE AND
THE WEATHER CONDITIONS THAT
EXISTED WHEN DRYNESS FUEL LOAD
AND ON TURNING OFF THE POWER.
HOWEVER THERE WAS THERE THERE'S
ALSO CONCERNED THAT IN PERHAPS
ONE CASE THAT THE POWER WASN'T
TURNED OUT- IN IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO. I THERE THERE ARE
REPORTS THAT. THE P. S. P. S.
DID. AND LEMONADE SOME OF THE
IGNITION SITES BUT THAT STILL
IS UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE
PC I'M JUST BASICALLY SAYING
WHAT'S IN THE PUBLIC. AND THE
PUBLIC INFORMATION OKAY. ALL
RIGHT TO LAST BUT NOT LEAST- I
REPRESENT THE CITY OF REDONDO
BEACH YES THE SIDE OF- ONE OF
THE ONES THROUGH COALINGA.
POWER PLANTS. AND I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THEM THE
MAYOR OF REDONDO BEACH WHO
TESTIFIED AT THE PC HIS HEARING
HE'S BEEN EXCELLENT IN IN- IN
HIS TESTIMONY AND THE
INFORMATION HE IS BROUGHT TO US
EIGHT HE'S A HE'S A TIRELESS
ADVOCATE FOR HIS- HIS COMMUNITY
AND I SHARE HIS- HIT HIS
PASSION- AND HIS COMMITMENT TO
WANT TO. SHUT DOWN THE REDONDO
BEACH POWER PLANT- YOU KNOW A
FROM THE COMMUNITIES
PERSPECTIVE- THAT THAT THIS
POWER PLANT- YOU KNOW HAS BEEN
PLANTED SHUT DOWN I BELIEVE FOR
AT AT AT LEAST A- THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS AND THEY THEY
COMMITTEE FEELS LIKE IT'S- GOT
THE ROCK. PULLED UP UNDER ITS
FEED WENT. IN NOT ONLY PLANNING
FOR THE SHUTDOWN OF THE POWER
PLANT BUT WE HAD IN FACT TO
SECURED TO ALMOST FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT DOLLARS TO. TO RESTORE-
THE ORIGINAL WEB- AT THE SIDE
OF THE PLANT. YEAH AND- MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS IT- AT THIS
POINT IS A- THE AT THAT
DECISION- IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING- NEEDS TO BE
FINALIZED WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. ARE IF
THE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. DENIES THE OR A DEAD I
AM NOT SURE WHAT THE PROCEDURAL
TERM IT WOULD BE BUT BASICALLY
TURNS DOWN THE- THE EFFORT TO
EXTEND THE WAS THROUGH CALLING
OPERATION AT THE REALITIES
PLANT. WHAT IMPACT WOULD THAT
HAVE ON. GRID RELIABILITY. YEAH
I'M A I'M TRYING TO ADD WHO HAS
BEEN A LOT OF THE ON THIS I'VE
BEEN I'VE BEEN SPENDING A LOT
OF TIME OF THIS AND I DO WANT
TO START OUT WITH SAYING THAT
THE- I KNOW THE COMMISSIONERS
DID NOT TAKE EXTENT OF MAKING
THE RECOMMENDATION OR BOARD TO
EXTEND OUR THE CIRCLE PLANE A
CALM EXPRESSION BATES LIGHTLY
AND LOOK FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OPTIONS. THE GOOD NEWS ELEMENT
THERE IS AN E. S. NIGHT CITY OF
OXNARD ACTION OF UP TO SUPPORT
A PLAN IN THEIR COMMUNITY ARE
POTENTIALLY STAYING OPEN AND I
THE LONG. RANGE FOR THE
OPERATOR OF THAT PLANT ON ON
PAGE INTO A MITIGATION FUND
REMOVE THAT PLAN LIKE A RED DOT
BEACH. THERE IS NO. FOR THE ACT
DEACON. I'M AND- I'M SO IF
WATER BOWL WERE. EVEN NOT PLANT
OPEN AND IN ADDITION YEAR OR
TWO YEARS THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
THE NEED FOR REDONDO BEACH IN
YOUR TO DO YOU SEE IT
RECOMMENDED LEAVING REDONDO
BEACH AND FOR TWO MORE YEARS.
IT IS DEAD IN. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BOND IF THE WATER BOARD
WORD TO DENY THAT- AT THAT
POINT IN TIME I DON'T. THINK
THERE'S A VOTE DOUBLE PLAN B.
THAT WOULD GIVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY STATE AS A
WHOLE- THE RELIABILITY THEY- IT
IF. EXTREME PEAK A YEAH. AND
THE AND THAT'S- THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE THE AND OUT THIS IS GOT
THERE'S GONNA THERE'S NOT-
UNTIL THE NEW SOURCES ARE BUILT
IN BOB THERE'S NOT A OPTION
THERE- WHAT I SAY IS
COMMISSION. I'M IS VERY IT TOO
AND TO GETTING THESE PLANTS
SHUT DOWN AS SOON AS PART FALL-
IF. THE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
ARE ABLE TO GET MORE RESOURCES
ONLINE SOONER- WE WOULD THEN BE
ABLE TO GO BACK AND SAY YOU
KNOW THESE PLANTS ARE NOT
NEEDED ANYMORE AND THEY CAN BE
CLOSER. ALL RIGHT. UP THERE HAD
A QUESTION BUT- WAS GRILL IS
PURE. ASKING A QUESTION ON THIS
PARTICULAR. YES POSITION YES I
THINK- IT'S REALLY MORE OF A
COMMENT THAT I HOPE THAT WERE
ALL ABLE TO WORK ON TOGETHER
AND THAT IS IN THE SETTING OF
ANY FACILITY ALSO COMES AT THE
COST OF A LOT OF JOBS A LOT OF
GOOD UNION JOBS A LOT OF. JOY
ALLOW TUNING REMEMBER BE ABLE
BE A I AM A HOME. IN THE NECK
COLLEGE BEING ABLE TO FOOD ON
TABLE AS WELL AS- DURING A
HOMELESS. AND HELP BASIS
PROCESS STAY. LIKE LOSING JOBS
IS NOT A PLACE WHERE WE WANT TO
BE. HOWEVER THERE IS I THINK A
SENTIMENT. THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND SO ON HOPING TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO FACE CERTAIN
ISSUES UNDER DISTRICTS AS WELL
AS OUR LEPER PARTNERS TO FIND
SOME. SOLUTIONS THAT ARE FEEL.
GOING ON THE JOB PAYS YOU BUT-
THERE'S HOUR AGO TO A JOB THAT
IS YOU FIFTEEN. AN HOUR.
DIFFERENCE YEAH AND I THINK
IT'S CHAO. THE BASIS JUST. ME
WITH YOUR- PARTIES ISSUES OR
FACE. WELL AS- THAT WE TO DO
WHAT SIDE. FINDS MISSION TO.
SURE SANTA THANK YOU I TO THE
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE WAS GONNA
TRY. THE IDEA OF THE TEST WE
TALK ABOUT JUST TRANSIT RIGHT
IN THIS QUITE A AS A RELATES TO
THE TRANSITION OUR CON. I
WANTED AND I RECOGNIZE THAT I
GOT WHEN OF THE CASES CAN BE.
CAN HERE BUT JUST ONE MAKE SOME
COMMONS THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THE COURT WORKING WITH
EITHER TO AREAS OF MUCH INTO
TO. ME THAT. NOT ONE IS ISSUE.
WORST PERFORMING. G.
SELECTIONS- STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
BASED ON ENERGY- GIVEN- THE
NEED- THAT WOULD EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE GREAT BUT ALSO.
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT IN MY IN
A REPRESENT PRO ME. AND THIS
AMOUNT WALDRON ENERGY UP. TO
SIX IN AROUND SOME SERIOUS. THE
OTHER TWO THAT ARE REALLY BACK
TO WHAT. A FOLLOWER TO A
DIFFERENT SECTION THE BIGGEST
FANS BUT- ARE HERE AND WE- IT'S
ON THE- OCTOBER. TO CONTINUE.
IN CAN. I'M WE HAVE PASSED THE
BILLS EVERY YEAR. EXPECTING THE
CALIFORNIA SIR VANCE THE SCHOOL.
NINE DOLLARS TEN IN IT BOB
STRUCTURE DOT CITY CAL. AND YOU
KNOW JUST FACT IS CAME UP AS A
TECH WAS SO BE TECHNO WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY. TO BUILD ON
THATAND START EGGMAN THAT WE
CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION IN
HIS HEAD OF ABOVE THE DIN
SHOULDN'T. IN THE VERY
INTERESTED IN GOING ON
OVERSIGHT BOARD THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
ALL OF THE SUBJECTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REALLY. YOU WERE
TALKING RAPE TALKING KEEPING UP
LOW AND IF. FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND I'M I'VE GOT A
TREMENDOUS UP. IT IS IN THAT
LOOK AT TYPE OF WORK IT'S BEEN
DONE THERE. LOOK AT EVERYTHING
FROM INVEST INTO IN FOR. TO
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS LIKE THE
LIFELINE PROGRAMS AND AGAIN
ANOTHER FALL UNDER MY
COLLEAGUES JURISDICTION OVER
HERE BUT JUST WANTED TO PUT.
THOSE MARKERS OUT THERE AND
LOOK WELL THE- BOARD TO HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY. L. WILL
TURN TO. STIR SANTIAGO WHO IS
THE CHAIR OF A COMMUNICATIONS
AND CONVEYANCE AND- IT BECAUSE
YOU'RE HERE AND BECAUSE IT WAS
ALSO IN THE REPORT- TOUCHING ON
VARIOUS SECTORS OF WHAT THE PC
IS OUR TOLL AND HAS- HAD
PROCEEDINGS AND ISSUES IN
ADDRESS IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
GOING ON. WE'RE NOT GONNA BE TO
FINALLY DEFINING JURISDICTION I
THINK TODAY BUT CERTAINLY AS
RELATES TO ANYTHING INDICATIONS
WERE MISTER SANTIAGO AND HIS
LEADERSHIP THERE BUT- WE'RE NOW
NOT LEAD TO THE APPROPRIATE. IN
IN RESPECT TO THE COMMITTEE SO
BUT WHAT WOULD I DO WANT TO GET
BACK TO THE NAM PROGRAM AND
CERTAINLY I'D BEEN SOMEBODY WHO
PORT- ROOFTOP SOLAR. ENERGY AND
ALL THAT TO MAKE OUR MUCH
BETTER BUT BUT THERE IS THAT
ONE IN I MEAN TO BE THE HORSE.
PRESIDENT WELCOME THE DECISION.
IS A- AT THE BILLION DOLLAR CO
SHIFTING AND I. THE SECOND JUST
CHECKING THE STATUS. I'M NOT
ALL OF IT IS COVERED- UNDER
UNDER- FOR MOST OF US PUBLIC
UTILITIES SMALL PORTION OF IT
WHICH IS THE CITY HUNTING PARK
ABOUT HAS TO BE. THAT ALSO HAS
TO BE WITH THE POOR THERE'S A
PERCENT AND SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CAUTIOUS TO ME THERE'S A
SENSE OF URGENCY- IN ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE AND WHAT THAT MEANS
AND I KNOW YOU YOUR NEW
POSITION. UP BUT AT. BUT THOSE.
OKAY THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ANSWERED YET IS SUPPOSED TO BE
DONE INTO THE- NINE. WHEN WITH
THE URGENT NEED- THE BEFORE THE
P. YOU SEE- THAT THEY WEREN'T
ABLE TO ADDRESS IT. IS THERE
ANY SORT OF COMMITMENT THAT YOU
CAN GIVE US THAT IS GOING TO.
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE GIPSON
NUMBER- BECAUSE WE NEED IF.
BEFORE YOUR TIME EIGHT EIGHT
FAILED TO MEET ITS FIRST
DEADLINE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- AND SO WE'RE NOW SEE
HERE TWENTY TWENTY- WRAPPED CAN
HIDE. ACOSTA HEALTH THERE IS A-
INCREASING TUITION I GET ANY
BETTER I CAN GO ON AND ON AND
ON AND MY DISTRICT FELL FROM
THE- THIRD. DISTRICT THE SECOND
DISTRICT. I GOT A MASTERS ARE
FOLKS RIGHT. AND WHAT IS AN
ANSWER COSTS. IN YOU'D BE ABLE.
THAT. I JUNE. IS ABOUT BY THE
END. ARE WE GONNA. ON ANOTHER
YEAR. WELL I. WE WERE. TALKING
ABOUT THIS. YEAH ARE EARLIER
AND I DON'T KNOW TO CAN EXPAND
MORE ON THAT THE TERM OF TIME
FOR MY- PLAN TO STAY. OF CUTS
FRUSTRATION. SORRY I UNDERSTAND
YOU CONCERN AND FRUSTRATE I
THINK THAT MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
RANDOLPH DISK IT'S SERIES OF
EVENTS THAT WERE GOING THROUGH
OUR PROCEEDINGS IF YOU WILL AND
WITH WITH THE TIME OF USE AS
WELL AS WITH. I'M ED CAN I
SUPPOSE ANYONE ON ANY OTHER
TIME FRAMES THAT WE OULD HELP-
MISTER SANTIAGO WITH. THE
BIGGEST COMMITMENT IS WERE
START- AND YOU'RE NOT ATTACKING
INTO THE BIGGEST COMMITMENT IS
WE ARE STARTING THE PROCESS AS
I SAID I KIND OF GLOSSED OVER.
AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THE INITIAL- COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS- THAT WILL BE NEEDED
TO MAKE THE NEXT DECISION AS I
SAID BEFORE THAT- THE TWO
BILLION DOLLAR COST SHIP NUMBER
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. IT IS
BASED ON A STUDY WITH BET ON IT
ALL BREAK. NOW THAT WOULD. BE
NEW RAGE. REFRESH SEVEN MY
THINK THAT NUMB ACTUALLY UP
BEING LOWER BY ALL ON THE FLIP
SO THINK THAT OLD STUDY YOU
COULD LOOK AT IT IN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT WAYS AND HOW YOU
DEFINE SHIFT I THINK GOING
FORWARD WILL BE CLEARER- BUT
THAT YOU KNOW WHO'S BENEFITING
WHO'S NOT WILL MAKE IT MUCH
EASIER TO THE DESIGN A NEW
PROGRAM- COULD WE GET SOMETHING
DONE BY JUNE CAN WE- BE. THE
WELL THE ARE WAY TO MAKE IT
THIS. EARLY NEXT YEAR- I THINK
THAT'S A DISTINCT POSSIBILITY
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE REALLY
HOPING FOR. HIS OWN REASONS AYE
AYE MA'AM MISTER. IS ONE OF THE
REASONS I ASKING I'M-
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT. BUT IF THE
FOLKS IN MY EAR I CAN'T AFFORD
IT. AND DON'T HAVE IT. WHAT'S
THE COST TO THEM WHAT MANY IN
IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AT THE
OTHER SIDE REMEMBER THAT THE
SOLAR PROGRAMS- USED TO HAVE
TWO PARTS TO IT. THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INITIATIVE
WHICH WAS A STRAIGHT GRANT
REBATE PROGRAM- FOR PEOPLE PUT
IN POPLAR ROOTS THEN THERE'S
THE NET ENERGY MERELY PROGRAM
WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO STICK TO
SELL BACK THE SOLAR THAT SEAT
PROGRAM IS BY AND LARGE
EXPIRED. BUT IN THE INTERIM
WITH THE PC HAS IS ALMOST ALL
MONEY THAT'S GOING OUT AND BE
SORT OF GRANT FOR REBATE FORM I
DOUBT GRAHAM OKAY STAND TYRONE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ENTIRELY ON PEOPLE LOW INCOME-
HOUSING EITHER SINGLE FAMILY OR
MULTI FAMILY. COMMISSIONER ARE
PER NOT SURE AND MITCH A HIGH
MILLION. YOU MONEY GOING TO THE
SUBJECT RATIONS AT THE PROGRAM
60% OF THAT IS THE TARGET IS
ON- DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS SO THE PROBE.
IS NOW ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
GETTING TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE- EARLY IN THE
PROGRAM. WELL GO BACK AND TAKE
A LOOK FROM THEN SOME OF THE
NUMBERS- IF I'M PROVEN WRONG I
WILL ADMIT BUT I'D BE WILLING
TO BET MOST OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT. DON'T
HAVE A- I'D I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT'S BECAUSE
THESE PROGRAMS ARE GETTING
STARTED OUT- NOW WINNER I
HIGHLY FOCUSED ON THE NOW. A
LOT OF CREDIT- COMMISSIONER
MARK THE GOOD SEVEN AS-
TIRELESSLY NOW THAT I CAN I CAN
ATTEST TO THIS BECAUSE- I GET A
CALL FROM. ALMOST DAILY ON CAN
YOU MOVE THIS QUICKER CAN YOU
MOVE THIS QUICKER HAS GOTTEN
THE COMMISSION LIGHTNING
FOCUSED ON- THESE COMMUNITIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE AND- CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAMS. MAY I ASK THE
CHAIR. AND MAY CONTINUE TO
CHAIR. YES I JUST WANT TO AND I
APPRECIATE YOU AND WE WERE
GIVING EVERYONE A CHANCE TO
SORT OF FLUSH OUT THERE
THINKING ON IT I JUST WANT TO
BE ABLE TO- MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER AT- FOR QUICKLY AND
THEN PUBLIC COMMENT SO BY ALL
MEANS IF IT'S A QUICK WELL AS
ONE IN BY THINKING YOU'VE
FRANCE OF THE QUESTIONS AND
WELCOME YOUR POST AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK. BUT I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE AN IDEA OF WHY
IT'S POINT TO ME WHY THERE'S A
SENSE OF URGENCY- TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE BECAUSE OF THE-
BECAUSE- WE NEED. WE YOU'RE NEW
TO THE POSITION BUT- WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS CRISIS TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. MISSED THE
FIRST DEADLINE IN NINETEEN. WE
DON'T WANT TO MISS TWENTY. AND
THEN HIT TWENTY ONE AND WE'RE
STILL TALKING ABOUT THIS. I
THOUGHT I WOULD JUST. BAG THE
MAYBE WE COME UP WITH A WITH A
REAL HARD DEADLINE WHAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT DEADLINES IS YOU
KNOW. IF YOU DON'T SET A
DEADLINE KNOWS GONNA MEET. AND
SO I AM HOPING THAT SOME POINT
COMPENSATOR STAIRS THE DEADLINE
TO MEET URGENCY AND I
APPRECIATE IT GREATLY- AND I
WILL TAKE THAT BACK TO MY
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS AND IF
THERE IS MORE THAT WE CAN DO TO
KEEP YOU INFORMED. AT TO ME. GO
THROUGH THESE PROCEEDINGS WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY DO THAT HAPPY
TO DO IT. BUT I DO HAVE A
STRONG SENSE OF URGENCY AND I
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT. I'M I
JUST WANT TO ASK A REAL QUICK
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO THIS
NEW SAFETY BOARD- ESTABLISHED
UNDER TEN FIFTY FOUR AND-
RECOGNIZING THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
GOAL WAS TO ENSURE- A MORE.
NIMBLE APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES OF SAFETY AND ALSO
CREATING AN AVENUE A PATHWAY
FOR A MENISCAL ON UTILITIES TO
ALSO HAVE THEIR WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS EVALUATED AND
ONE. STOP PROCESS OF THE
WELFARESAFETY BOARD I BELIEVE
HAD ITS FIRST MEETING THIS WEEK
YESTERDAY YESTERDAY AND SO THE
SO A LOT OF THINGS ARE
HAPPENING YOU'RE IN THE
POSITION YOUR AND- THERE'S
CLEARLY TRANSITION HAPPEN IN
TERMS OF MOVING THE- ELECTRIC
GRID DIVISION- SAFETY AREA OUT
OF THE PC AND INTO. A RESOURCE
AGENCY THE QUESTION GIVEN
DISCUSSION TODAY AND AS WE KNOW
TO BE THE CASE. THE WORKLOAD
USE THE AS IT RELATES. VARIOUS
ISSUES DO YOU THINK THAT IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO MOVE ALL
GAS- SAFETY AND ALSO ALL THE
UTILITY OR ARE I SHOULD SAY-
ELECTRIC SAFETY WORK. INTO THE
NEW DIVISION- AS IT IS RIGHT
NOW IT'S- THEY'RE STILLKIND OF
A SEPARATION SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS. BECAUSE TAX UP THE
WOULD BE. APPROPRIATE TO
TRANSITION ALL SAFETY RELATED
ACTIVITIES AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
I WOULD REALLY HAVE TO STUDY
THAT- I HAVE BEEN IN CHARGE OF.
SEVERAL REORGANIZATION PLANS
AND STATE GOVERNMENT. MIGHT
STIRRED UP THE DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA AND TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION WITHIN TWO WEEKS
OUT OF B. O. E. CREATED THE
OFFICE TAX APPEALS WITHIN SIX
MONTHS I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO
DO TRANSITIONS AND
REORGANIZATIONS. AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST THAT ONE HAS TO DO A
REAL EVALUATION OF WHAT IS THE
OBJECTIVE WHAT WHAT WILL MAKE
IT BETTER WHAT FUNCTIONS
GOVERNMENT WILL BE MADE BETTER
BY THAT REORGANIZATION OR THAT
RESTRUCTURING. AND THEN WHAT
DISRUPTION WILL OCCUR TO THE
CONSUMER. TO THE PUBLIC AND TO
THE EMPLOYEE IS OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS- SO YOU WANT TO
AGAIN LOOK TOWARD GOVERNMENT
EFFECTIVENESS NUMBER ONE. AND
THEN HOW DO YOU APPROACH IT
WITH THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
DISLOCATION AND DISRUPTION FOR
THE PUBLIC SERVICE THAT YOU ARE
CHARGED TO PROVIDE. SO THOSE
WOULD BE GUIDEPOSTS FOR ME IN
LOOKING AT NOT. ON I ALSO. THE
MOVING OF A DIVISION FROM ONE-
UNDER ONE UMBRELLA ONE AGENCY
TO ANOTHER ONE IS NOT A SMALL
FEET EITHER. I'M JUST JUST
SIMPLE BUREAUCRATIC STUFF THAT
I CAN MENTION THAT IS SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED IS THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION LIKE SO
MANY STATE DEPARTMENTS WHICH-
IN MY OTHER JOB I TRIED TO
CHANGE- AND ARE STILL SERVICE
IMPROVE. WE HAVE OUR OWN
SPECIAL CLASSIFICATIONS SO OUR
PAY SCALES ARE DIFFERENT OUR
CAREER LADDERS ARE DIFFERENT
OUR- RESPONSIBILITY JOB JOB
DUTIES ARE DIFFERENT. AND
MOVING. THE FOLKS THAT ARE
HIRED UNDER THE UNDER A P. YOU
SEE CLASSIFICATION INTO A NEW
ORGANIZATION CAN BE DONE IT
WILL BE DONE IT'S NOT DONE
EASILY BECAUSE IT SCREWS UP
FOULS UP THE LADDERS AND-
LETTERS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT'S JUST
WONKY CIVIL SERVICE STUFF WHICH
I WISH I WOULD COULD HAVE SAT
WITH FOLKS AND TALKED ABOUT
THAT. A YEAR AGO NOW ON. BUT
ANY RATE I WOULD REALLY
SERIOUSLY WANT TO KNOW WHAT WE
WERE IMPROVING AND HOW WE WERE
IMPROVING IT. UNDER REORGANISE
IT IDEA. AND WHAT WOULD BE THE
BENEFIT IN TERMS OF REALLY
SAFETY THE OBJECTIVE OF MAKING
THINGS SAFER WHETHER IT'S GAS
ELECTRICITY- MILD HER
MEDICATION. ON AND WHERE TO
WHERE TO MOVE IT IS RESOURCE IS
THE RIGHT PLACE TO MOVE GAS
SAFETY. IS RESOURCES THE RIGHT
PLACE TO MOVE. RAILROAD SAFETY
OR SOME OTHER PART OF THE
SAFETY RUBRIC THAT THE UC- IS
IN CHARGE WITH I DON'T KNOW
MADE A STANDALONE ORGANIZATION
THAT REPORTS DIRECTLY INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THAT MIGHT
BE A LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
KIND OF. THIS THING TO CONSIDER
I'D REALLY NEED TO THINK I
WOULD JUST CAUTION YOU DON'T DO
REORGANIZATIONS AND GOVERNMENT
LIGHTLY ON. WHEN IT'S BEEN DONE
LIGHTLY OR POORLY WHETHER IT'S
BEEN DONE BY THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH UNDER THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION. PROCESS IT'S
DIFFICULT AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GET IT RIGHT BECAUSE OF AS I
SAID THE IMPACTS TO THE PEOPLE
WE SERVER TO MIGHT AND IMPACTS
TO INPUT PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IS
CAN BE TOUGH TO. WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR- RESPONSE- IT
CLEARLY WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. SOLUTIONS TO COMPLICATED
PROBLEMS WHERE THERE ARE THINGS
MOVING UNDER OUR FEET YEAH- SO
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES IF
YOU WILL IT'S EASIER TO SORT OF
FIGURE IT OUT AND THAT'S IDEAL
AND I KNOW THAT THINGS
HOPEFULLY ARE CALMING DOWN A
BIT BUT AND THAT. AS TIME GOES
ON AND WE CITY THE MITIGATION
PLAN START TO TAKE HOLD THE
HARDENING OF THE GRID- THE-
CLEARING OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND THE THINGS THAT
WE ARE WE'RE CALLED OUT A NINE
A ONE IN TEN FIFTY FOUR START
WE BECOME PART OF THE- EVERY.
DAY EXPERIENCE OF UTILITY TO DO
THEIR PART AND FOR THE AGENCY
TO REGULATE ACRO APPROPRIATELY-
THAT WE WILL. HOPEFULLY DARK TO
START TO SEE A REDUCTION AND
THE KIND OF FIRES THAT WE'VE
BEEN SAYING BUT IN THE
MEANTIME. WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
CONTINUE TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE THINKING THROUGH
EVERY- APPROPRIATE- STRATEGY
THAT ALLOWS US TO BE IN THE
BEST POSITION. TO BE REVERSED.
THE RE. PLACE THEIR REALLY NEED
TO AND TO BE TO HAVE THE OF- I
DON'T WANT TO OVERSTATE THE
WORD YOU'VE GOT IT IN MY HEAD
NOW NICHOLAS TO BE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE THE KIND OF-
RESPONSIVENESS TO THE ISSUES AS
THEIR UNFOLDING- AND I'M AND
AGAIN YOU'RE THE RIGHT PERSON-
AT THIS TIME- TO DO THIS JOB I
MEAN I. I COMPLEMENT THE
GOVERNOR FOR SELECTING YOUR
COMPLEMENT. YOUR COMMITMENT TO
PUBLI SERVICE TO STEP IN TO
THE ROLE AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. CONTINUING TO FOSTER GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE P. USE
THE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP AND TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE FOR. COOPER
LATER DROPS SHARPLY CHANGING
ENVIRONMENTS ERNEST CHANGING
TIME I KNOW MISTER MURATSUCHI
SAID YOU HAD A VERY QUICK
BECAUSE I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE MY
TRANSITION TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER. OF IT IS TO HAVE A
QUICK. YEAH MEAL YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED.
QUICKLY LOCATION THIS CHURCH.
THE TRANSIT ELECT TO VIRTUAL. I
KNOW THAT OFF. THE YOU KNOW
COMMON ARE MADE IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT. THE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS THE
STATE ARE NEEDED TO
SKYROCKETING ELECTRICITY RATES
BUT IN MY READING OF THIS CHART
RIGHT THAT THAT IT'S- SHOWING
THAT IN FACT AT LEAST FOR.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
EVEN P. JEANNIE THAT IT LARGELY
SEEMS TO BE FOLLOWING INFLATION
EVER SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
YES I MEAN. THE POINT WHERE I
MADE EARLIER IS AS THE JAN ME
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE CHART
ALSO EXCEEDS- AND THE OTHER
POINT I WAS MAKING AS AS-
DEMAND DECREASES- AND THAT'S
WITH EFFICIENCIES WHICH IS WE'D
WANT. AND THAT THAT SOME OF
THESE RATES WILL CHANGE IS IN
OUR MODEL AND OUR PREDICTIONS-
BUT I READING THAT CORRECTLY. I
I'LL TAKE THAT A STEP FURTHER
YOU TAKE THIS ALL THE WAY BACK
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY YOU WILL
SEE- CALIFORNIA- ELECTRICITY
RATES TRACKING INFLATION BOB
OVER THAT TIME PERIOD ALMOST
PERFECTLY UP UNTIL THE LAST FEW
YEARS- FOR ONE UTILITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AS A MATTER WE
APPRECIATE YOUR BEING HERE
TODAY WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
PROBABLY STILL OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT MEMBERS WOULD LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO POST TO YOU BUT WE-
ANTICIPATE AS TIME GOES ON
WE'LL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE HAVE
FORMAL AND INFORMAL
CONVERSATIONS TO. MAKE SURE
THAT WERE ALERT TO. YOUR ALERT
OUR THOUGHTS AND VICE VERSA IF
YOU COULD- IF YOU'RE NOT IN A
RUSH WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO
STICK AROUND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE. ELIZABETH THOSE WHO WILL
BE HERE REPRESENTING THE- IT'S-
A MAKE A PRESENT. THEN WE'RE
GONNA HAVE. TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
IF ANYTHING COMES UP DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME IT'LL BE
BRIEF NO ABSOLUTELY I LIKE THIS
ISN'T IMPORTANT DAY AND NOW I
WOULD ABSOLUTELY. IF YOU COULD
WOULD BE DISRESPECTFUL FOR ME
NOT TOO LONG AGO AND I FIND IT
THANK YOUS- MISTER CHAIR SO
MUCH FOR YOUR KIND REMARKS AND
THAT OF THE OTHER MEMBERS. AS I
SAID I HOPE YOU CAN STILL SAY
THE SAME THING IN SIX MONTHS.
AND I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
AGAIN WHAT I SAID IN MY-
OPENING REMARKS THAT I REALLY
DO LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATION I WANT TO HEAR
YOUR IDEAS ARE STAFF. WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ALL
ON THESE IDEAS AND KEEP YOU AS
INFORMED AS POSSIBLE YOUR
QUESTIONS OF AN EXCELLENT
TODAY. AND I SO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THEM. THANK YOU. BUT
NOW AT THIS TIME I LIKE TO ASK
GOES WITH ECHOES THE DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATES TO JOIN US.
WELCOME
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CHAIRMAN HOLDEN AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
TALIBAN ENERGIES COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY AS YOU KNOW MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH ACKLES I'M
DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. WITH ME HERE
TODAY IS LINDA SERRA'S OUR MY
DEPUTY OVER ENERGY. DR NET
SKINNER OUR MANAGER FOR A
SAFETY BRANCH AN ANA MARIA. I
COMMUNICATIONS POLICY AND I'M
JUST GONNA READ OUT OF A VERY
QUICK ADVISORY FROM OUR
ATTORNEY MY TESTIMONY MAY
ADDRESS ISSUES AND A JUDY JUDY
A COURT DURING OR RATE MAKING
PROCEEDINGS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PENDING BEFORE THE CPC WHERE
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AS
A PARTY THEREFORE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH COMMISSION RIPPLE EIGHT
POINT THREE SEE THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE FILED A
NOTICE OF MEDICATION AND THE
APPLICABLES PROCEEDINGS. THERE
ARE CBO DECISION MAKER
LISTENING TO THIS PART OF THE-HEARING ANNA AT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE WILL BE SINCE. SOME OF
THE SENSOR STAINED. SO AS YOU
KNOW THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE IS THE INDEPENDENT
CONSUMER ADVOCATE AT THE SI PC.
OUR MISSION IS TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE LOWEST POSSIBLE UTILITY
RATES FOR CALIFORNIANS
CONSUMERS CONSISTENT WITH
SAFETY RELIABILITY AND THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. WE
PROVIDE A VOICE FOR MILLIONS OF
CONSUMER. ANY OF WHO DON'T HAVE
THE TIME OR RESOURCES TO
NAVIGATE THE STATE'S COMPLEX
PROCESS SEES. LAST YEAR OUR
DEDICATED TEAM OF ANALYSTS
ENGINEERS AND ATTORNEYS FILED
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED PLANES AND
PC THE- AND- PAID HUNDREDS OF.
MEETINGS. AN ACTION AS YOU HAVE
YOU PROBABLY HAVE MY MICE IF
YOU WANT TO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
THE SLIDES- I'M NOW ONE SLIDE
THREE WHICH IS CUSTOMER
SAVINGS. SO OUR HARD WORK PAID
OFF FOR THESE CONSUMERS THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE SAVE
CUSTOMERS MORE THAN FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION AND LOWER UTILITY
REVENUES AND AVOIDED RATE
INCREASES LAST YEAR. NEXT SLIDE
POLICY ADVOCACY OUR GOAL IS TO
ACHIEVE THE BEST VALUE FOR
CONSUMERS ACROSS THE REGULATED
INDUSTRY SECTORS. ENERGY WATER
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS SO THAT
EACH DOLLAR INVESTED IN
CALIFORNIA'S UTILITIES ACHIEVED
THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE RETURN FOR
CONSUMERS IN TERMS OF THE STATE
SAFETY RELIABILITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. SLIDE FIVE
MOST OF THAT FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION IN SAVINGS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER IS THE RESULT
OF OUR ADVOCACY AND TEN GENERAL
RATE CASES OR G. R. C.'S AS
THEIR DESCRIBED. TO BRIEFLY A
G. R. C. IS A PROCEEDING IN
WHICH A UTILITY REQUEST
APPROVAL TO RECOVER. THE FUNDS
IT FORECAST THAT IT WILL NEED
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD AND
SOMETIMES A FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
AND G. R. C.'S ARE THE LARGEST
AND MOST COMPREHENSIVE
PROCEEDINGS AT THE P. YOU SEE.
WHERE THE ONLY PARTY THAT
CONDUCTS A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW
OF THE UTILITIES APPLICATION
WHICH ARE TYPICALLY THOUSANDS
OF PAGES LONG. IN SOME G. R.
C.'S THAT INVOLVES SMALLER THE
UTILITIES PARTICULARLY IN WATER
AND COMMUNICATIONS WERE THE
ONLY PARTY EVALUATING THEIR
PROPOSALS. SO LOOKING FORWARD
NOW IT IN I WANT TO STRESS YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY AND CONCERNS
ABOUT SKYROCKETING RATES- WE
ARE CONTINUING TO PUSH FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING THE COST
IMPACTS ON CUSTOMERS BILLS
ACROSS INDUSTRIES AND IN
PARTICULAR- TAKE TO KEEP A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF KEEPING
UTILITY SERVICES AFFORDABLE IS
KNOWING HOW THE COSTS OF ANY
ONE PROPOSED UTILITY PROGRAM
MIGHT IMPACT THE CUSTOMER'S
BILLS. THIS INFORMATION WILL
ENABLE THE CPC TO PRIORITIZE
UTILITY PROPOSALS CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE'S POLICIES IN A
MORE TRANSPARENT MANNER. SO WE
HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT THE PC
REQUIRE UTILITIES TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THE CUMULATIVE
IMPACT OF RECENT AND PENDING
FUTURE M. INCREASES SO THAT
THEY CAN LOOK AT THESE
INCREASES. AS A WHOLE AND NOT
JUST IN A PIECEMEAL FASHION
WITH EACH EACH DIFFERENT
PROCEEDING. WE'VE DEVELOPED A
TRACKING TOOL THAT WE BELIEVE
UTILITY SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT WHEN PROPOSES TO RECOVER.
COSTS FROM CUSTOMERS. WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THE PC'S
CONSIDERATION OF AFFORDABLE
UTILITY SERVICES INCLUDE
DIFFERENCES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BASED ON KEY FACTORS SUCH
AS TEMPERATURE GEOGRAPHY AND
COST OF LIVING AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS TO DEVELOP AND
AFFORDABILITY FRAMEWORK TO
BETTER IDENTIFY THE AREAS OF
THE STATE MOST IN NEED
INCLUDING OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. FOR NOW I CAN MOVE
FORWARD TO THE SAFETY SECTION
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL-
CALIFORNIANS PAY FOR AND EXPECT
SAFE AND RELIABLE AND
UNFORTUNATELY TWENTY NINETEEN
MARKED THE CLOSE OF A DECADE
PUNCTUATED BY NUMEROUS UTILITY
CALLS BECAUSE CATASTROPHES. THE
TWENTY TEN NATURAL GAS PIPELINE
EXPLOSION IN SAN BRUNO THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN- LISA CANYON
STORAGE GAS LEAK AND THE
MASSIVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILD FIRES
THESE INCIDENTS RESULTED IN
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTH TALENT
STOP BECAUSE OF HOMES AND
BUSINESSES DESTROYED AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT ARE NOT YET FULLY
KNOWN. AND OF COURSE LAST YEAR
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT. IT
CALLED CULMINATED IN ENERGY
UTILITIES DECIDING TO SHUT OFF
POWER TO MILLIONS OF CUSTOMERS
TO REDUCE THE RISK THAT THEIR
FACILITIES WOULD CAUSE MORE
WILD FIRES. AS YOU KNOW THE
START UPS WREAK HAVOC ON
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND PUT MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS AT RISK
SUCH AS OUR ELDERLY CHILDREN
AND THOSE WHO DEPEND ON
ELECTRIC POWER MEDICAL DEVICES.
THE SORT OF THOUGHT HIGHLIGHTED
OTHER SIGNIFICANT SAFETY
RELATED ISSUES SUCH AS THE NEED
FOR COMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
INSTALL BACKUP POWER TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN CALL FOR HELP
OR CALL THEIR LOVED ONES IN
CASE OF AN EMERGENCY. EVEN WHEN
THEIR POWER SHUT OFF. SO I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF OUR SAFETY
WORK IN TWENTY NINETEEN
STARTING WITH THE NEED FOR
RELIABLE WIRELESS SERVICE
DURING POWER SHUT UP. WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE PC EXIT
THE THIRD TO REQUIRE WIRELESS
COMPANIES TO INSTALL BACKUP
POWER IN THEIR FACILITIES AND
TO EMPLOY ALL MEANS NECESSARY
TO WHAT THIS. IS MAINTAINED
STE. HOURS FROM THE START
ELECTRICAL OUTAGE. WE ALSO URGE
THAT SI PC TO ASSESS THE
UTILITIES DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES TO ENSURE THAT THE
UTILITIES WILL SHUT OFF POWER
TO CUSTOMERS ONLY AS A- TRULY A
LAST RESULT RESORT. WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT YOU SEE
REQUIRE UTILITIES TO
IMMEDIATELY ENSURE THE ACCURACY
OF THEIR LIST OF CUSTOMERS
PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH SPECIFIC
ENERGY NEEDS DUE TO MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. I ALSO WANT TO
BRIEFLY MENTION A LISA CANYON
AND THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
LEAK THAT HAPPENED. WITH SO CAL
GAS IS A LISA CAN'T NOT.
FACILITY WITH SUBMITTED
TESTIMONY THAT PROCEEDING THAT
IDENTIFIES THAT SO CAL GAS DID
NOT KILL. THE NECESSARY
ANALYSIS OF UNDER COVERED KURT
BUSCH AND IN ONE OF THE AISLES
AT LEAKED AND THAT UTILITY IS
MISSING CRITICAL SAFETY
INFORMATION. OUR WORK IS
ONGOING AREA. I'LL LOOK FORWARD.
EVEN WITH THE RIGHT NOW WORK OF
THIS BODY IN THE GOVERNOR'S AND
MAY OTHER AN AROUND THIS CLEAR
WE STILL FACE SIGNIFICANT
WILDFIRE THREATS. AND NOT ONLY
DO WE FACE THE CHALLENGES OF
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
THEIR PROPERTY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT ARE KEPT SAFE BUT
WE MUST ALSO ADDRESS CUSTOMERS
CONCERNS REGARDING THE COSTS OF
THE MONTHLY BILLS AND THE
RELIABILITY OF THEIR UTILITY
SERVICES. SO I WILL BE VERY
CLEAR THAT OUR PRIORITIES ARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LIGHTS
STAY ON THAT UTILITY SYSTEMS
ARE SAFE AND DIMMERS DO NOT
FOOT THE BILL FOR ANY TELL THE
MISDEEDS. WITH THIS IN MIND WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A STRONG
VOICE FOR CUSTOMERS ON THESE
ISSUES. SO FINALLY BRIEFLY ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT. SOME OF OUR WORK
IN SUPPORT OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
REACHING THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS IS CRITICAL
TO THE INSURANCE ENSURING THE
WELL BEING OF OUR RESIDENTS.
WERE FOCUSED ON ADVANCING THE
STATE GOALS AND THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER POSSIBLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT AGGRESSIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS CAN BE
ALIGNED WITH PROVIDING SAFE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE UTILITY
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE WE
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATE FOR
UTILITY TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD ENABLE INCREASED
APPOINTMENT OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. MAP SOME MONEY MY
SEEN THE BENEFITS OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. THE MICE IN THE COST
IMPACTS TO RATE PAYERS. FOR
INSTANCE ARE SO WITH SDG E.
REGARDING THEIR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM RESULTED IN SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN CUSTOMER
SAVINGS WHILE DOUBLING ESTY
CHENEY'S ORIGINAL PROGRAM
GOALS. ARE ADVOCACY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT THE RATE PAYER
FUNDED EVEY CHARGING PILOT
PROGRAMS PROVIDE IMPORTANT
LEARNINGS FOR FUTURE POLICY WE
ALSO FOCUS ON EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO EVEY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
TO ENSURE THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
BENEFIT. TRANSPORTATION ON THAT
OCCASION. GOING FORWARD WILL
CONTINUE ADVOCATE LOAD SERVE.
MEET THEIR- TO PROVIDE RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY SERVICE CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE'S GOAL OF GHG
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND COST
EFFECTIVENESS AND WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO. AND WORK TO ENSURE
AFFORDABLE UTILITY SERVICES AN
ADVOCATE THAT USING RATE PAIR
FUND SHOULD ONLY BE FOR
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DEMONSTRATED
TO REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS ENSURE
SAFE DRINKING WATER AND PROVIDE
RELIABLE COMMUNICATION SERVICES.
SO WITH THAT I KNOW YOU'VE HAD
A LONG DAY SO I'M GOING TO WRAP
UP QUICKLY YOU KNOW CLEARLY
LOOKING FORWARD WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THIS
YEAR'S SUCCESSES AND WORK TO
ACHIEVE THE BEST VALUE FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ACROSS ARE
REGULATED INDUSTRIES. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE OKAY
WELL THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION AND THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT. YOU DO ON
BEHALF OF RATEPAYERS OF. ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I GUESS I WOULD
ASK AND IT RELATES TO A TEN
FIFTY FOUR- AND THE- WILDFIRE
FUND THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
USING- DUE TO BE OUR FUNDS. WE
WERE EVALUATING POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES OF THE UTILITIES
FOUND THEMSELVES AND THE WHOLE
THAT THE AND- AND THE COST THAT
THAT WAS BEARING ON RATEPAYERS.
CERTAINLY WITH THE FINANCING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
UTILITIES IN THE STRUGGLE THAT
THEY WERE GOING THROUGH OF THE
ONLY VIABLE SOLUTION- THAT CAME
FORWARD WAS TO EXTEND THE-
DELIVERY OUR CHARGE. AND THAT
CREATING THE FUNDED CREATED A
BALANCE WHERE SHAREHOLDERS PUT
MONEY INTO THE FUND AS WELL. AT
THINK ABOUT ALL. OF WAS
PROBABLY A REALLY APPROPRIATE
WAY TO SORT OF- HAVE A SOLUTION
THAT BROUGHT SHAREHOLDERS TO
THE TABLE WHICH HAD NOT
HAPPENED PREVIOUSLY AND THEREBY
RELIEVING SOME OF THE PRESSURE
ON RATE PAYERS. THERE WAS A AS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT- YOUR
OFFICE WENT FORWARD I GUESS
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF THE BILL
WITH. CONCERNS AND OPPOSITION
TO THE USE OF THE FUND. AND OUR
EXTENSION OF THE DATA BE OUR
CHARGE AND- I GUESS NOT HAVING
HEARD THAT CAN STE AND WHILE WE
WERE TO BE LIBERAL. AROUND THAT
SOLUTIONS. BECAUSE PAUSE AND
WONDER IF THAT WAS NOT THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO. WHAT OPTIONS
ARE WATER OF OTHER APPROACHES
WOULD YOU HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN. TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIACY OF THE CRISIS IF YOU
WELL IN THAT MOMENT- AND SO I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE MY QUESTION
OF BECAUSE WE HAD NOT GONE DOWN
THAT PATH. THEN WE WOULD. BE IN
A PLACE I THINK OF- EVEN
INCREASE PAYROLL AND- INCREASE
IMPACT ON REPAIRS IN PROBABLY
ANOTHER UTILITY IN BANKRUPTCY-
I. JUST THROW THAT OUT BECAUSE
I WAS A LITTLE I PONDERED. WHY
WE HAD NOT HEARD THE OPPOSITION
DURING THE FOUR OF. TEN FIFTY
FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEAR
CHEN I APPRECIATE THAT AND
CERTAINLY. IN THE FUTURE WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE. IN
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES AND RAISING ANY
CONCERNS IN REAL TIME- IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE ARE IN
A REALLY TOUGH PLACE IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO SET UP. A FUND
THAT COULD HELP UTILITIES TO
STATE. THE TO SPREAD THE COSTS
OF THE WILD FIRES AND TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY SERVICE- WE DID
HAVE SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FUN WE WORST IN
PARTICULAR WE WERE- THE INITIAL
LANGUAGE IT WASN'T ENTIRELY
CLEAR IF THERE WOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR. FOR UTILITIES
TO BE ABLE TO BE- PAID THROUGH
THE FUND AND THEN ALSO GO BACK
AND RECOVER THAT COST FROM FROM
CUSTOMERS- SO THAT THAT WAS
CLARIFIED OF BOTH BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND BY THE P.
YOU SEE THAT THAT WAS NOT THE
INTENT AND- AND SO THAT WAS
THAT CLEARED UP ONE OF OUR- BIG
CONCERNS- AND I THINK WHAT I'M-
GONNA DO IS. IS TURN TO DR
SKINNER AND SEE IF HE WOULD
LIKE TO. ADD ANYTHING TO THAT
BUT I THINK THAT WHAT THAT WAS
OUR BIGGEST CONCERN WITH WITH
THE FUND AND THAT WAS LATER
CLARIFIED. THE ONLY OTHER ITEM
THAT I WOULD ADD IS THAT THE
OTHER CONCERN WOULD BE. BECAUSE
THESE CHARGES ARE BEING. LEVY
IT PRIOR TO KNOWING WHETHER OR
NOT A PARTICULAR UTILITY MAY BE
PART OF THE APPLICABLE ENTITIES
FOR THE FUND IN THIS CASE PGA
ANY WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
SURCHARGES AUTHORIZED UPON ALL
P. JEANNIE CUSTOMERS. AND THEN
IF THEY FAILED TO EMERGE FROM
BANKRUPTCY- BY THE END OF JUNE
OF THIS YEAR. AND THUS WOULD BE
AN ELIGIBLE FOR PARTICIPATION
IN THE FUND P. GINNY'S
CUSTOMERS WOULD POTENTIALLY GET
CHARGED. BUT THE UTILITY WITH
AND BE UNABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
FUNDS TO THE LANGUAGE OF AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR. WELL I KNOW THAT AS
WE ARE. WATCHING THIS REAL TIME
AT THE TEL AVIV IS CERTAINLY IN
A PLACE WHERE BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE CPUC
THEIR CONVERSATIONS TO THE
COURT AND AS YOU HEARD OF THE
PRESIDENT. ARTICULATE THERE IS
GOING TO BE SOME TYPE OF
RESOLUTION THERE WILL BE SOME
FORM OF ENTITY I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT EMERGES OUT OF BANKRUPTCY
THAT WILL PROVIDE POWER TO- THE
SERVICE AREA WHAT AT ENTITY
LOOKS LIKE AND HOW IT
ULTIMATELY. IS STRUCTURED IS
STILL UNDER CONVERSATIONS AND
SO THERE IT IS A BUT WILL THERE
BE SOME ENTITY CALLED SOME
UTILITY THAT WILL PROVIDE POWER
TO COST CUSTOMER BASE THAT
STILL IS. IN A RISK OF HAVING
QUALIFIERS- STARTED THAT NEED
TO STILL PARTICIPATE IN A FUND
OF SOME SORT I THINK THAT THERE
WILL BE SOME KIND OF UTILITY
AND THERE IS A DEADLINE THERE'S
A WALL UP THERE. FOR A KNEE OR
SOME. KHAN TO EMERGE TO ALLOW
TO BE ABLE TO PROTEST SO I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION THAT THERE WOULD
NOT BE A UTILITY STANDING TO BE
ABLE TO AND HOPEFULLY IN A
TIMELY WAY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THE FUND PARTICIPATION. SO I
IT BUT I WAS CURIOUS IN TERMS
OF IF NOT THAT APPROACH THAN
WHAT. AND THAT'S WHERE MY
CONCLUSION- WELL THAT'S WHERE I
WAS COMING FROM YOU KNOW IF
THERE WAS THIS DOESN'T WORK
FROM YOUR VANTAGE POINT WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A BETTER
APPROACH. NO SIR THE ANSWER BUT
I'M JUST. THE KERR TO ME AND
THE MOMENT THAT I THOUGHT I'D
ASK YOU- IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. WHEN WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION EVERY YEAR AND WE
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK
THAT YOU'RE OUT THERE- TENDING
TO DO ON BEHALF OF REPAIRS.
WELL THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR GOOD WORK ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF US HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WILL. CERTAINLY ENDEAVOR TO
WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH YOU AND
YOUR TEAM GOING FORWARD LOOK
FOR TODAY AND YOU CAN STAY
WHERE YOU ARE- WE'RE I'M GONNA
TURN TO THE PUBLIC AND I'M
GONNA HAVE. THE UPPER FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE HERE AND STILL-
MAJOR WAY THROUGH- FAIRLY
EXTENSIVE HEARING. AND I HOPE
THAT YOU'VE LEARNED AND HEARD
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT TO
HELP YOUR THINKING. IF YOU'RE
IF THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS- I'M
OF THE COMMITTEES PREPARE TO
HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME- I WOULD SAY PROBABLY A
MINUTE OR TWO FOR EACH PERSON.
AND IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT CAN
AFFORD THE HE MIKE IS AVAILABLE
TO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A JOHN WHITE
FROM THE CENTER FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RENEWABLE
TECHNOLOGIES SUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THIS FORM OF
OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN THE
DEBATE I HAD A BOARD MEETING.
GOING ON IT JUST FINISHED SO I
WASN'T ABLE TO COME BUT I HAD
SOMEBODY LISTENING AND SO.
THOUGHT I APPRECIATE- THE
PRESENCE- A- COMMITMENTS AND
HER PRESENCE- BUT THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AT THE PC- I WAS PARTICULARLY
TAKEN BY- ED RENDELL'S COMMENTS
THAT THERE'S NO PLAN B. FOR THE
OTC. EXTENSIONS AND FRANKLY
THAT'S ON THE PC THAT HAD NINE
YEARS TO PREPARE. FOR THE
EVENTUALITY. THE OFFICES WERE
MADE TO THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THESE PLANTS ARE BUILT- AND NOW
WE'RE KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD AND WE DON'T HAVE A
PLAUSIBLE PLAN. FOR WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THOSE EXTENSIONS
ROVERS SO THAT'S THE FIRST
THING. THIS IS A PROBLEM THESE
ARE THE DIRTIEST LEAST
EFFICIENT MOST EXPENSIVE UNITS
ON ASSIST. AND THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE RETIRED. BASED
ON THIS IS NINE YEARS AGO
SECONDLY WE ARE MISSING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE NECESSARY
PROCUREMENT THIS IS WHY WE HAVE
THIS CRISIS IS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN SITTING ON THE ISSUE OF
PROCUREMENT- THERE'S CHALLENGES
WITH THE RISE OF THE CCA'S AND
SO FORTH BUT- THE OTHER THING
WE HAVE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
USE CREATIVE. A NEW
TECHNOLOGIES DEMAND RESPONSE
STORAGE HYBRID RESOURCES AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE PC IGNORE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON A CAL I SO
AND US ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE TO
ADOPT APPROPRIATE IN ACCOUNTING
RULES AND INSTEAD THEY WENT
WITH THE MOST RESTRICTIVE RULES
ANYBODY HAD PROPOSED WHICH WE
THINK IS GOING TO ENSURE THAT
THE UPCOMING PROCUREMENT WON'T
HAVE. AS ROBUST TO
PARTICIPATION BY PREFERRED
RESOURCES AS WELL AS WE COULD
HAVE SO WE THINK THERE'S MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE WE THINK THE
PROCESS HAS A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED WE
KNOW THERE'S A LOT ON
EVERYBODY'S PLATE FOR THE
BANKRUPTCY AND EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT WE DID WANT TO. HAVE A TO
CENSOR THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU. HELLO MARK TONY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK. IT JUST
MIGHT TAKE A QUICK OPPORTUNITY
TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
FROM TURN STANDPOINT. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE FEE P. YOU
FEE RECEIVE THE FUNDING AND
PERSONNEL NECESSARY TO BE ABLE
TO CARRY OUT THE INCREASED
EXPECTATIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
IN MAKING SURE THAT THE
INSPECTIONS ARE PROPERLY DONE
OF THE ELECTRIC EQUIPMENT TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES ANOTHER FIFTY
MEASURES. THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO HANDLE THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PLACED UPON THE
PC THE FED IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. AND THAT IN TERMS OF
FOLLOW UP FOR MAYBE. TEN FIFTY
FOUR. ENDING THE WILD FIRE
SAFETY DIVISION AND WHAT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE GOING TO
BE WHAT THE PROTOCOL FOR GOING
TO BE AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
AT NEW DIVISION HAS BOTH THE
PARTICIPATION OF INTERVENOR TH
AND CHECKS AND BALANCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DECISIONS IT IS
REACHING HAS A WIDE ARRAY. OF
INPUT AND PARTICIPATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER
SPEAKERS- LET ME JUST AGAIN
TURN TO YOU- DIRECTOR ECKELS WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND PRESIDENT
BACHELOR WE DO APPRECIATE YOURS
AS WELL I THINK THAT THIS IS
BEEN VERY HELPFUL- THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE ON THE TABLE-STILL AND WE HEARD A COUPLE
FROM THE PUBLIC- THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO GET OUR ARMS
AROUND- BUT I THINK THIS IS
BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN TERMS OF
STARTING OUR YEAR- TO GET US
OFF ON THE RIGHT TRACK IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE STILL.
ARE COLLABORATE IN WORKING IN
AREAS APPROPRIATE TO CONTINUE
TO TIE UP ALL THE LOOSE ENDS
OUT THERE IN THIS EVER CHANGING
UTILITY AND ENERGY WORLD- BUT I
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
AND WITH THAT- MUSSER ANY MY
MEMBER OR A- NO QUESTIONS
ASKED. RETURN.